it's entitled rabbi
in the podcast you have said that your
mother would like you to be a rabbi you
are a rabbi rabbi means teacher
that is what you're doing on
valuetainment economics and and that is
why his mother was so disappointed with
him last week when we started
and he said he didn't want to become a
rabbi anyways
welcome to tonight's podcast we have to
start
off with adam telling us the story about
him being a rabbi today we have a full
house we have
danielle de martino booth here with us
which obviously by taynor's you guys
always request her she's got
her own show uh uh down the middle
we got adam sosnick with us we got tom
zenner with us
and today uh for the first time with us
ricky aguilar who i think we can call
you capitalist
how how would you do this
hispanic proud hispanic latino
conservative capitalist
that's a good way of putting it so you
know kind of where he leans it's gonna
be a lot of fun today we have a lot of
things to talk about
and here's how it's gonna work out we'll
go for the first hour kind of going
through some of the issues
eight o'clock we'll watch the debate
together live we'll go till 9
30. we'll comment on it and then 9 30 to
10 30
we'll debrief with uh what thoughts
everybody has so while you're watching
this
put the thumbs up share the debate let's
get a bunch of folks here together and
let us know what's on your mind with
tonight's debate but
i think the first thing for us to talk
about before we get right into it is
who's campaigning who's raising money
who has momentum
what's really going on kai can you pull
up uh uh what
what trump's done lately maybe he showed
a picture of trump's campaign
where he's been the last week show the
picture where he's been carolina i sent
it to you
sam has it uh uh sam did you give that
one to him or not yet
how was that one picture i sent you to
where he's been i sent you guys i said
airdrop it
if you don't have that go to what jake
tapper said about biden recently on that
one minute
because i think the big concern with
democrats is biden hasn't been out there
debating or campaigning
campaigning specifically at all the last
week rewind it back
and play that president's having but joe
biden didn't have
any events yesterday i'm not saying he
should be having unsafe events
but why is he taking a day off with less
than three weeks to go before the
election
jake joe biden has campaigned tirelessly
but he has campaigned safely and as you
saw this past week
during the national town halls that both
of them held
it is a sharp contrast between president
trump who's
frenzied who continues to lie just
incessantly morning noon and night
uh and pres excuse me former vice
president biden
uh who is laying out
show it to us so for one week no one's
seen him
and then this is what uh uh trump's been
doing campaigning if you got the pig
do you know the pick i gave you with uh
sam
there you go so that's him the last week
okay oh wow
ohio nevada florida
carolina i think today he had to sit
down with 60 minutes
right afterwards they went out there
campaigning
and so it's going to be an interesting
strategy what do you think about this
whole strategy right now because
it seems like biden's team is kind of
saying the same thing over and over
again he's preparing for the debate he's
preparing for the debate he's preparing
for the debate he's preparing for the
debate
while trump is out the campaign
campaigning who do you think this is
benefiting right now going into
tonight's debate
well i mean obviously you're getting a
lot more more energy out of the trump
camp but i think
from the democrats perspective at this
point it's do no harm
it's like the hippocratic oath don't
mess up and
you know i i think they're just holding
their breath and hoping that
the president says something sticks his
foot in his mouth somehow
those are the people that just got in
okay though that doesn't count the
people that are probably trying to get
it yeah that's a frenzy okay
that's a movement right there um what
about the fact that biden is not
campaigning because he's scared
because he doesn't want to face these
questions that is the only reason he is
not campaigning right now
you won't get that from cnn because
they're not allowed to say hunter biden
on the air either as abc
they don't mention the word one time
hunter biden they do not say it
in my opinion he's not campaigning
because he doesn't want to face these
questions
what is he going to do lie i mean this
is this is turning into
something pretty big and pretty
important here in the final week adam
what do you think
well i mean he's going to face these
questions tonight tonight that's the
whole point
is he tom we're about to find out in an
hour are we not i mean that's what's
going to do that the moderator has to
ask the questions
well i think we can all agree i'm not
saying she will but she should
ask the tough questions to both
candidates yeah
well she should be able to job big
difference
national security is a subject and this
would be a matter of national security
would it not
allegations involving the the chinese
communist party would definitely be
some aspect of national security so
especially given
what's come out in the media today
because there has been this this steady
drum beat from journalists saying if it
can't be corroborated we can't report on
it
well if if there is corroboration in the
form of something on a hard drive emails
from more than one entity then all of a
sudden it's something that the moderator
should be bringing up ricky what do you
think i well when it comes down to him
my campaign first of all my grandmother
had a saying
i'm gonna tell you in spanish i'm gonna
translate it she said
right which meaning that you defend
yourself more just not saying anything
right so i actually we were talking
about it i don't want to jump ahead of
the schedule but
we're talking about you know they're
turning off the microphones i think it's
it's a double a a lot of people don't
like it it's double leg short for me i
think so i think it's a great idea
because what is what is body going to
say for 90 seconds
or two minutes he's incoherent so
you give him a chance to put his foot in
his mouth he's gonna do it and i can't
wait for him to do it during this debate
if they choose
to moderate the time ricky you're uh
you're from where where's your family
so so you yourself you consider yourself
a conservative capitalist
my my my all my dad was an entrepreneur
i've never heard my dad call anybody
boss no
any of his brothers and sisters my dad's
an entrepreneur
and we are conservative in we love our
country we love god
we love our families and we like our
rights protected i mean it's it's it's
i think every hispanic doesn't realize
they're conservative or every latino at
least or anybody
everybody in general but i think mostly
for us from where we come from
it's family god make your money take
care i mean it's
very basics so as a as a hispanic i'm a
more
a more and where by the way we're pro
we're pro
uh uh pro-life right because as a matter
of fact a lot of people don't know that
some people might agree some people
might agree i know some parts
of the catholic religion depending where
you live do not even allow people to use
condoms which makes sense why our
grandparents had so many kids so we are
about life
and i'm looking at a lot of you know
modern hispanics or progressive
hispanics
that don't want god involved right in in
the system
don't have a big problem whenever you're
talking about pro-life or pro-choice
and and they're getting they're getting
away from the values and principles that
our grandfather
our grandparents and our parents taught
us so the ones that want to treat
with that i'm a latino i'm hispanic rasa
if you're really that way
then you are naturally conservative you
remember when george w
ran for uh his second term as texas
governor
it was a hispanic landslide here in
texas
landslide by the hispanic community
right so i mean you you are absolutely
correct i grew up in san antonio texas
but you're absolutely correct
that it is it it is all about god and
family it's a great point why why do you
think i mean you you get into with your
community a lot
you get into it all the time all the
time you know you you've converted a lot
of people to get into the way of
thinking of who they really are but
why do you think a lot of hispanics it's
the fastest growing community in america
population wise voting wise i mean it's
the future the way it's going right now
demographics
yeah demographics why do you think they
vote sixty-four percent vote democracy
so i
i have to go a little deeper okay so my
dad
when my dad was fifteen years old living
in mexico the bible was on spanish
i mean we don't speak spanish we speak
castellano castano castellano which
speaks question
the bible in mexico was latin
up until my dad was 15 years old my dad
is he was born 1957 so figure up into
the
late 60s early 70s the bible wasn't was
not in spanish it was in latin
okay but the catholic religion or just
religion in general
in mexico has been there since after
they killed the aztecs off in the mayan
zone
so the reality is this my dad says i
don't even know why i followed a certain
religion
it's just because they told me hey this
is the bible kissed him he said there's
a word of god
so what what does it teach us about
hispanics we're very trusting you
right so we might not even be able to
read it but if you've seen enough time
by the way hitler said it
say the lie repeat the lie that believe
the lie right i'm almost like i'm
talking about the religion i'm just
saying
as a hispanic community in mexico we're
very trusting when you say we want to
help you
we're very trusted so whenever you jump
on the news like telemundo
and you listen to jorge ramos which is
supposed to be for us and you say
this is original bad you're like yes you
don't you don't do your homework you
don't do your research
you don't you don't dig deeper just
because another man with your same skin
color from your same country
that is also an immigrant says so you
believe him that's the problem with the
hispanic community
nobody goes deeper everybody just says
oh mexican must have my
my interest in my best interest at heart
i'm going to believe him
so when you start looking at you know
we're reading through all the laws and
everything you know for example i mean
here we are we have hispanics voting for
the man that was a vice president what
four million people got deported
the most in history on top of that the
cages were built when he was a vice
president
so you're talking about rasa you if
you're trump you're bad
you're you're a traitor but you were
voting for the man that was vice
president for eight years as our people
got deported and built the cages you're
hypocritical but you don't only better
because
jorge ramos told you not to believe that
well i mean so i i i will speak in
defense of many people from mexico who
are not too terribly impressed with the
idea of a wall
100 100 so i'm just just just saying i i
said it i said it yesterday i posted it
on facebook
a lot of people the wall is racist every
single president has added to the wall
right every president barack obama said
that he was going to go against he
the anchor baby think he's the one that
brought it up so
as a why put it on facebook issues okay
if you don't believe in the wall you
don't believe in ice which is
basically the security the cops of the
border it's very simple
open put on social media with your
addresses open up your windows open up
your doors and don't call the cops when
strangers come into your house
because they might be hard-working
americans that sounds like new york city
these days
that's and it makes sense well they've
converted so many people but
if you don't like a wall and it look do
the do the do the
the the the trial at your house first
before you want us to open up our
country
why don't you open up your house first
go open up your doors your windows leave
them open all day all night let anybody
come in go to your refrigerator take
your food do whatever sleeping in
whatever room they want
and just not know who they are don't ask
them for id don't ask them for
blood don't ask because who knows i mean
they might just be good hard working
americans ricky do
they take the newscaster series still
has that much power as an anchor 100
a news anchor to a certain extent is
equivalent to a
to a to a priest because you just think
they're hispanic they're the i watch
you're gonna think this from the morning
to the end
they watch the morning news tell the
novellas which are so popular
people live for turnovers in the
hispanic community it is
it is the i grew up around the like one
of my crushes her name is rui some of
my hispanic followers can remember it
was a soap opera called ruby
and so they watch these people from
morning tonight
so they almost allow them into their
it's my dream job to be on a soap opera
oh my god you look like a soap opera guy
i mean if you look at that he looks like
you're so popular
and that's your job what
i got a question
yes so you said you think the wall is
racist
no no no i said hispanics think the
waters are something expensive
from hunter biden by talking about the
wall right are we talking about wait
we're talking about the world
we're talking about hispanics every
every sovereign country has a wall and
so they should okay cool i'm with you
i said multiple times that people like
you that look like you tatted up
gangsters i might say need to actually
join the republican party which you are
and run for office right you could talk
about it all you want unless you run for
office and someone sees
damn that dude ricky's my guy it's all
just
mouth talking right right just take him
out when someone like you runs for
office
that's when people are gonna wake up
okay that's number one
number two but this is the truth though
because major is running for
for office right now and you don't see a
whole lot of california he's running
against losing he's a black republican
that's i'm not talking about i'm talking
about latinos but the black community is
just as tight as our community
so if they were if that was the case
then why isn't major making any noise in
california
well let's talk about numbers now okay
pat said 65 was 64 65
of latinos vote for the democrats that's
35 republican
90 of african americans vote democrat
right
okay what is trump doing what is trump
doing
to bring more latinos into the
republican party
what is trump doing to bring more
african americans
right into the community because in my
opinion he's not helping no he you know
i agree with you adam his link here's
the thing you gotta remember
hispanics are very emotional people you
know who else is emotional yes
everybody everybody no no okay but
latinos for sure they were extra
emotional like we cried on the soap
operas
doesn't make sense like you just don't
say that there's no latino friends out
there
we take it so serious the problem is the
problem is
in the hispanic community we take things
that we shouldn't take as serious very
serious
and things that we that we should take
seriously not as serious so i'm sitting
here i was having a conversation with
the with an individual yesterday on
facebook as well
through messenger if i can show you all
the bills and the laws and everything
that
trump has done to help the hispanic
community
would would that change your mind no why
because f
trump they're not trying to hear the
facts no they don't want to hear their
emotional group it's emotional no no of
course
they're extra emotional creatures extra
most people are emotional
but latinos are extra that's why by the
way that's my wife is right here that's
why i love being married to a mexican
woman because you're very passionate
but that passion comes at a cost yeah
she'll cut you off that passion is going
to come at a cost
so sometimes erica just just put away
the
so again uh she woke up in the middle of
the night because she had a bad dream
and just slapped just slapped the crap
out of me you're like i'm sleeping oh
yeah
obviously i'm like did you hit me for
something i might do but here's the
problem here's the problem
let's get back to the point the point is
this and when you when you talk about
the hispanic community
and you think about this like i said uh
uh trump is not
appealing to minorities because his
language
so what's the first thing he ever said
the first thing he ever said ricky what
was it let's build a wall you want to
build a wall not to build a wall
that these people are coming across the
border they're rapists
they're drug
and some other initiations are to gang
rape gang rape or to murder
so so if i grab a bunch of sound bites
and say oh
you you grab he said they were racist
murders drug dealers
and he says i'm assuming some people are
good well
let me let me i'll put you this way if
i'm at your door
with 15 different people i said adam let
me in but you don't know any of them
are you going to assume they're all good
or that you're going to or you're going
to say i don't know any of you guys
you can i can't i can't assume that
you're good i have to assume that you're
going to harm my family inside my house
all right let's step back for a minute
two times now in public
trump has been given the opportunity to
to denounce white supremacists
but two big stages tonight's is the
third opportunity to say
yes people who are against people of
color are not
with me this is his third opportunity on
a big big big stage to go there
yes do you think he's going to go there
he just did it on the town hall and he
said how many times do i have to do it
but at what point will it be enough for
him to do it is there like an official
time he can do it like
frustrated by answering it like tom are
you a racist you
i don't play those games i don't i don't
you're not going to answer it but i i
that that's
to adam's point he needs to
but there's a part of it there's a part
of it that
the question makes the audience assume
that at one point he was so
the question itself has a lot of power
behind it so
even when somebody says do you still
hate your wife i've never hit my wife
before
if i ask you three times in three
separate interviews the audience is
going to be like maybe he does it his
wife nobody knows about it
the questions have a lot of power behind
them you sit there and you watch
questions being asked on both sides it's
not the same thing
anyways what this was good for if you
didn't know
ricky now you know ricky this is who
rick he is you know his position
since we have some stuff we got to do
before we get into the debate can you
pull up
can you pull up uh how much money trump
has raised versus biden because buying's
been on fire lately
raising money pull up the data here's
what it's looking like
so biden's raised 1.35 billion dollars
so far
trump's raised 1.49 billion dollars so
even though it looks good that trump's
raised more
if you look in the light blue and the
light pink in september alone
biden's raised 358 trump 153 nearly two
and a half times more if you go a little
lower
to see what these numbers are looking
like where it's coming from
uh that's september we kind of looked at
number go lower there's one of the
things i wanted to show
uh on how the numbers look trump victory
okay those are those are good keep going
lower is that it
okay is there anything lower or no okay
that's that's what i want to look at
okay so you see the spikes like yeah you
see the hockey stick
so what does that hockey stick represent
is it representing
the last minute panic is it representing
you know bloomberg just came in and cut
a big check and that helps the number
tremendously is it represent what is
that hockey stick
representing is it we better figure this
thing out because if this guy gets in
and stays another four years we're all
screwed what does that mean it is not
even
it's naivete because you just don't ramp
up the tv commercials and think it's
gonna sway anything
who watches tv anymore who watches these
commercials
people that have already made up their
mind old people you know anybody that
really watches the news or watches
network television from 8 till 10 i
don't nobody else does here's the other
thing about trump
you think he's lacking in tv coverage he
goes to these swing states
draws 25 000 people at a rally
and owns the news cycle people can see
through these ads there's no one stupid
enough that would listen to a tv
commercial right now and think
man a light bulb just went off i like
this box the light bulb went off after
the debate
you know what that money is a big part
of that i mean that was a huge deal
200 million of it but do you think
that's a true individual
do you think the individual is an issue
right now do you think if some if either
side needed money right now they
would have it in a second it's how they
prioritize it i don't think
trump is prioritizing tv ads right now
and the other thing is
there is a chance that one of these
sides no more than we do
this polling data might be inaccurate
there he might not need
as many tv commercials as the general uh
populist thinks that he does
well where it will be effective
nationally i think maybe you're right
locally in swing states
in certain cities in wisconsin in
detroit
in certain cities in north carolina in
certain cities
in florida in certain cities in arizona
i'm not turning my television
right now they're worried about that's
where they're putting them on of course
congress and senate races because those
are the ones that are very very close
very contentious and that's going to
make almost as much of a difference as
who's president and that's where a lot
of money in and that's what the ads are
going
right now you're not going to get
legislation done if you can't flip one
of the houses it's just not happening
you'll have more gridlock i'd say you
know what really worried me and
a lot of people don't i forgot who was
saying that i think it was on maybe it
was cnn because i watched cnn because i
just if i want to be entertaining here a
bunch of lies
i watch cnn so um but anyway point is
this
um somebody said i can't remember if it
was como if it was
lemon he said if body becomes president
he needs to pack pack the back to court
that's scary that hasn't happened in 150
years
you're so saying when when you're
already insinuating that as a president
this is what you should do
that's a very scary language and this it
goes back to
a little bit of what pat was saying
these are the type of things that our
hispanic community doesn't hear
they don't know deep enough issues they
don't know that packing the court is
a horrible thing to do and and nor
should
nor should you do it but when you have
anchors of people that are naive
listening to them and you say pac that's
very that's a scary thing i mean
anybody voting for buddy you should do
your homework and realize that
because if i mean should trump pack the
house i mean
what should you do or park the court
what should you do
it's a naivete on the latino community i
don't think
most people have ever even heard of i've
never seen until like a month
no kidding i've been 40 years on this
planet i've never heard back in the
morning
you're not packing the club when the
club gets too full but this is
the insinuation the insinuation of it
it's a scary thought
that the anchors that are influencing
everyday americans are saying this
well joe biden did say that he will make
an announcement on packing the court
before he's that he has so let's see if
he can the good news is for people who
don't do their own fact checking
the independent organizations that
follow americans reading the
constitution
the american readership of the us
constitution has gone through the roof
right and there's no social media and
that's a beautiful thing
i mean it is so awesome it's like what
what people didn't do in high school
they're going back and doing and we're
learning about our founding fathers and
our roots i mean there's some pretty
awesome stuff happening because
americans are curious because all they
hear are sound bites they don't get any
subs since they're like okay i'm gonna
go find out for myself
the debates are not helping they're not
getting any substance in the debates
because some people are not answering
the questions other people are
interrupting people in the mirror
you know well how do you feel about the
microphone muting after two minutes
muting before two minutes before no i
don't
mind that not when you've got 13 minutes
to have a food fight after per
question 13 minutes is plenty of time
for them to go after each other so you
like
you like the beauty just for the first
two minutes i mean i'm sorry
whether it's biden or trump if you can't
have 120
himself no i think he is i think he's
going to force biden to talk more
tonight yeah
and that's it that's how he's going to
hurt himself
trump can stick with his game plan
tonight which is a big
whatever that's a huge right but i think
that's part of their strategy is let
biden kind of
you know by the way today a lot of
things have happened today
okay one amy coney barrett
they voted for 12 democrats didn't show
up so 12 10 if you want to put it there
12-0
for them not showing up to george floyd
you heard about uh
you know the whole thing they didn't
think that the third degree murder could
could stick yeah so that's the second
thing that happened today which again
more frustration thing third uh the
sasha cohen borat
ii clip came out with rudy giuliani in
the
interview he got spooked and which is
hilarious i know you've been following
the story
i mean that in itself i was thinking
when it came to october surprises yes
could flourette's timing have been any
better because
you know how they do the top one if he's
not in the top one i mean this guy is a
brilliant
and the great thing
so that's that part and then on top of
that we had a couple other stories you
guys
tony we had 60 minutes which is the 60
minutes the interview that uh
yep uh leslie trump did with leslie with
leslie stahl
and then they did it with uh biden i
think even pence
and trump and she was upset and she said
she's never interviewed biden
there was confusion there on the
president's part she has personally
never interviewed biden 60 minutes has
60 minutes has interviewed him but not
leslie and i mean
after listening to 30 minutes that was
like two people attacking each other so
he was attacking her as a
person like her on the air anyway she's
always uncomfortable well but
did you see the first time she
interviewed him or no probably when he
became a president like four years ago
yeah
yeah so and in that whole part but but
the biggest factor about this is it's
supposed to be launched this sunday
because pence sat for the whole
interview yeah he did so they have they
have air they have plenty
to put on the air you watched the whole
thing what did you think about it
because
before anything i can't say it like try
at least say what it looks like
like you imagine you're an actor you're
in a movie
your girl is recording the scene and
before the movie comes out you publicize
the scene to everybody so
60 minutes is doing the interview
somebody's sitting there recording him
before 60 minutes plays it on sunday he
plays it so everybody tonight cannot say
that he walked out
yeah goes live with it what was your
take when you watched it so i mean
again it wasn't i didn't take away
anything of substance from it
and that is an increasing source of
frustration
i think i don't care who you're talking
about democrats or republicans
you're like i want to learn what they
think about that's substantive instead
of just listening to two people fight
yeah if i want to listen to two people
fight you know i wouldn't put my italian
i mean
yeah i mean i could just go find a
relative so but i don't
i mean i i'd rather hear policy and i
think
that's what americans are ready for
she obviously they both got hot under
the collar do you think
she was she was irritated and he was
here sorry anything do you think it was
smart on his own
my second master's is in journalism so i
think he crossed a very dark line
oh my god in doing that what did he do
wrong i mean you come to his house
you roll cameras he didn't break into
cbs and steal
videotapes he didn't vote he broke with
protocol
and that was just they're they're not
going to not air what happened between
the two of them it's just you're going
to get to see both of their faces you
know what cbs is doing backflips right
now
do you understand the numbers on sunday
night because sunday night's going to be
people are going to want to know
what their version of what happened is
right but but we're talking about right
and wrong
and what he did was not right yeah but i
mean is it fair to say that they've also
done the same thing to him with the
whole collusion with russia
i mean my point is had anything of
substance come out of the 37 minutes
but for me it was just it was just a
stunt but
he walked out of the interview and he
wanted to set the record straight i
don't think there's anything wrong he
didn't stay for the entire interview
they said sir you've got five minutes
left on air and he said no
and i mean he didn't like you know rip
off his microphone and and storm out
but he did can you pull it up but he
didn't get up in later trump's facebook
it's not really
you know if you go to trump's facebook
page i hope you don't need to log on but
he could have just as easily played that
one little segment that showed i didn't
storm off yeah
you know what i think the biggest
motivation for the people the
journalists doing the interviews
they want to impress their peers they're
doing these interviews for the kudos
that they get from their colleagues
and their bosses she could have got some
substantial information and really
answer some questions he never has but
they're so busy
being in attack mode and trying to
impress their peers
don't keep going no you're right it's
about to come it's the next one i think
oh they took it down no that's it okay
no that's it so make it bigger
make it bigger isn't this amazing
go to 36 minutes here's how it ends
raise the volume
okay played 4.7 million views in six
hours that's a very frustrating that's
what
that's what he wanted that's what he
wanted he wanted the view
i didn't want to have this kind of money
of course you did
no i didn't wish well then you brought
up a lot of subjects that well i
they were inappropriately uh right from
the beginning
now your first question was this is
going to be tough questions well
and you set up the interview your first
statement was president
don't you think you should your first
statement to me
this is going to be tough questions well
i don't mind that but when you set up
the interview you didn't say that
you said oh let's have a lovely
interview and and here's what i do say
you don't ask joe biden i saw your
interview with joe
the interviewer i never did a job it was
a joke
the interview 60 minutes i see joe biden
giving softball after softball i've seen
all of his interviews
he's never been asked a question that's
hard okay but forget him
no but you start with me you're a
president excuse me leslie you started
with me
your first statement was are you ready
for tough questions
yeah that's no way to tell them
lastly one second
uh this is the first warning i think we
have
five minutes until we have the vice
president is that about right
well i think we have enough really we
have an essence yeah i think we're ready
for that
now i think we have enough of an
interview one of his aides comes on and
rescues him okay he just gave her 40
minutes but danielle if there's
anybody here's the thing i i get how
frustrating he could be but if there's
anybody in politics that is definitely
not
one that sway you know avoids being
interviewed and doesn't go into heat
you know when sitting out with this this
guy everybody
else obama did a once with uh uh what do
you call it he sat down once with
hannity
not hannity um uh all right you remember
that one interview
and then you never saw it again he'll go
on cnn fox msn he'll go
anywhere to do it so i don't think it's
the thing about him wanted to step away
she flipped her uh
uh request that she had at the beginning
my only thing is i'm sitting there
thinking about look okay
why did he share it so is he sharing it
because he doesn't want anything to be
asked tonight that's going to hurt him
is he trying to
what's what's his motive of sharing this
that's what i'm trying to find out
he's sharing it to give a glimpse of
what the
motivation is with the media and and
just how they try to spin
something and how well today like why
did he do it today
wha what was in here he was worried
about him he did not get people stopped
talking about rudy giuliani
was there's no corroboration it cannot
be verified that was it was said over
because the
the hunter biden business came up
probably four or five times in the 35
minutes they spoke
and she kept repeating after herself it
can't be verified
we cannot report on it if it cannot be
corroborated what if trump knew this was
coming out
what if trump knew that corroboration
itself was coming out today what better
timing could there be
on which side on on
the actual they could validate these
emails right and prove them that the ceo
of a company
the gentleman who came out and said i
have i have the physical emails in my
possession
that the post published so why don't we
go so that's that is that is
straightforward corroboration
and that's what you said before right we
when we weren't even recording so check
this out i said there's been five big
stories today right we talked about amy
coney barrett this guy george floyd uh
rudy giuliani the 60 minutes and this
guy here's what he says before he even
watches
by the way generation after generation
in the navy this guy
this guy was friends if you haven't seen
this by the way
he may actually be at the debate tonight
trump is trying to bring him to the
debate tonight similar to our last time
he brought bill clinton's uh mistresses
yeah
accusers accusers not mistresses
accusers oh it was
and he's trying to do the same thing
accusing
mistresses
and tony comes out today
tony was a friend of hunter biden and he
drops the bomb
in the first two minutes press play on
this one
is talking to the media right now armed
forces since leading the navy
i've been involved in various successful
businesses both in this country and
abroad
i'm making the statement to set the
record straight about the involvement of
the biden family
vice president biden his brother jim
biden and his son hunter biden in
dealings with the chinese
i've heard joe biden say that he's never
discussed business with hunter
that is false i first hand knowledge
about this because i directly dealt with
the biden family
including joe biden i have also heard
that vice president biden said on
tuesday that senator ron johnson the
chair of the senate homeland security
committee
should be ashamed for suggesting that
biden family sought to profit from their
name
well here are the facts i know and
everything i'm saying is cooperated by
emails
whatsapp chats agreements documents and
other evidence
and american people can judge for
themselves i brought i guess
for record three phones
the years 2015 through 2018.
unbelievable
i've never been held by anybody else
besides myself i was told this past
sunday by somebody who was also involved
with the matter
it would vary phones why is that bad if
everything of the text that's in there
it's homework
the more contributions i've made have
been the democrats what do you mean
what's up
i'm asking like what do you think okay
let him finish you're actually asking
that question i want to hear
what's in the phone he just showed me
three things what he says
the emails in dispute in the new york
post
why did you do this weeks
because they're holding on to something
go back because we have to hear what
there's
what this guy's saying they're holding
on to so go back to
hear the key words go back i think it's
like at 40 seconds let him play again
because i think adam missed it
folks forgive us adam uh uh maybe very
good with finances when it comes down to
selective hearing
he doesn't hear the things that he
doesn't want to hear he showed me three
phones like a drug
play it one more time go ahead go ahead
there's a lot of drug dealers in my mind
president biden said on tuesday that
senator ron johnson the chair of the
senate homeland security committee
should be ashamed for suggesting that
biden family sought to profit from their
name
but here are the facts i know and
everything i'm saying is cooperated by
emails
whatsapp chats agreements documents and
other evidence pause
okay go back one more time for nine
seconds adam
listen very carefully to what he says
it's proper everything he's saying
for the chats i gotta play it again
family sought to profit from
their name well here are the facts i
know and everything i'm saying is
cooperated by emails
whatsapp chats agreements documents and
other evidence
yeah and the american people can judge
for themselves so i guess he's guilty
you know what he was campaigning he used
the corroboration word he said
corroborated
and he's showing you where the evidence
is
i was told this past sunday about
somebody who was just listen so involved
in this matter
that if i would publish this information
it'd be it would bury all of us man
the biden's included i have no wish to
bury anyone
i've never been political the few
contributions i've made have been the
democrats
but what i am is a patriot and a veteran
to protect my family name
and my business reputation i need to
ensure that the true facts are out there
in late 2015 i was approached by james
gillier whom i had known for many years
about joining him in the deal which he
said would involve the chinese
state-owned enterprise
cfc china energy and what he called one
of the most prominent families in the
united states
i was informed first by gilliard and
then by hunter biden and by rob walker
who was working with the bidens that the
bidens wanted to form a new entity with
cfc
which was to invest in infrastructure
real estate and technology
in the us and around the world and the
entity would initially be capitalized
with 10 million dollars
and then grow to billions of dollars of
investment capital after months of
discussion
i agree to gillian hunter buying's
request to become ceo
of the entity to be called cynohawk
cyano representing the chinese side
hawk representing hunter biden's brother
bo's favorite animal
and between february and may 2017 we
exchanged numerous emails documents and
whatsapp messages
concerning sinohop and its potential
business on may 2nd 2017
the night before joe biden was to appear
at the milton conference
i was introduced to joe biden by jim
biden and hunter biden at approx
at my approximately hour-long meeting
with joe that night we discussed the
biden's
history the biden's family business
plans with the chinese with which he was
plainly familiar at least at a high
level
after that meeting i had numerous
communications with hunter walker
gillier and jim biden
regarding the allocation of the equity
ownership of sinawalk on may 13
2017 i received an email concerning
allocation of equity
which says 10 percent held by h for the
big guy in that email there's no
question that h stands for hunter
big guy for his father joe biden and jim
for jim biden
in fact hunter often referred to his
father as the big guy or my chairman
on numerous occasions it was made clear
to me that joe biden's involvement was
not to be mentioned in writing but only
face to face
in fact i was advised by gillian walker
that hunter and jim biden were paranoid
about keeping joe biden's involvement
secrets how bad is this
i also had a disagreement with hunter
about the funds cfc was contributing to
science
you couldn't understand his family
so he wanted the funds wired directly to
an entity affiliated with him
i objected because that was contrary we
did speed it up if you're watching this
1.5 maybe 1.25
father that cfc was really investing in
the biden family
that he held the trump card and that he
was the one putting his family legacy on
the line
he also said to me on may 17 2017
that cfc wanted to be my partner to be
partnered with the bisons
during these negotiations i repeated the
hunter and others
that sign ohio could not be hunter's
personal piggy bank
and i demanded that proper corporate
governance procedures be implemented for
capital distributions
hunter became very upset with me csc
through
through july 2017 was assuring me the
funds
would be transferred to signohawk but
they were never sent to our company
instead i found out from senator
johnson's september report
that the five million dollars was sent
in august 2017
to entities affiliated with hunter
tomorrow
i will be meeting with the senate
committee members concerning this matter
and i will be providing to the fbi the
devices which
contain the evidence cooperating what i
have said
so i will not be taking any questions at
this time
did you hear the end of it where you
said that they they moved the money
to hunter they they kicked him out of
the deal so he's pissed yes
that's unbelievable what do you think
about this adam adam tell us what do you
think about this
i mean i think joe biden just dropped
out of the race right now he's just
dropped out what do you i know you're
emotionally pissed off but what do you
think about this okay some dude shows up
the day before election i've never heard
of this guy and all of a sudden i'm
supposed to be like
defending this or that the other how
pissed would you be if you got screwed
over in a deal like what are his
what's his reasoning
let me ask you guys let me ask a
different way here's a different
question for you
so when the dossier came out everybody's
famous question was what
what if this is true what should they do
to trump right
what if this is true
yeah there's going to be legal ram
affirmations what if this is true
this is going to be legal ramifications
which means what what what if freaking
knows i just heard of joe bubba
liske for like the minute and a half we
watched him
no clue they've been talking about
hunter biden for
years now and they've nothing stuck
biden's winning in the polls still
despite
joe hunter biden's salacious activity
is this going to be enough to put him
over the top we'll see they should bring
this up i'm not asking
i'm not asking if it is anything to put
him over the top does it do anything for
you as a voter
what like there's some dude like
speaking for a minute
he doesn't do anything for me really if
they actually approved
this guy he's
if everything can be proven if
everything can be proven
that these talks have been had and that
is the agreement
where are you at you where are you at
position wise
some dude yeah making a speech yeah does
nothing for me
if actually legal ramifications happen
yeah
then yeah how many times did you bring
up russia with trump
did i yeah we can go on the entire
podcast run it back every single time
zero yeah but russia was done when you
started of course it was because it was
done but prior to that
what did you think when you saw the
russia thing with trump trump's up to
some shady stuff with russia you thought
about that you know
why you jumped to conclusion that was
never the case it came back it was all
over the tv
wait a minute this is on tv so you
believe that well you don't believe this
this is on tv for a minute and a half
but you know what here's i'm a trump
it's not about being a trump fan how
many people hate trump on the republican
side
yeah ted cruz talks [ __ ] about him okay
lindsey graham talks [ __ ] about him
um jeff bush talks [ __ ] about him yeah
every single one of these guys talk [ __ ]
about him
and what did you say well of course they
lost to him he slaughtered them
why would he not be spiteful against
this this is not so this dude got
screwed over by 100
deals why would he not let me just know
that
it's a whole different story because you
don't put yourself out and make yourself
the biggest name in the country now
right before the election his life's in
danger 100
literally you don't do something upside
down because he has so much integrity
because he said he's a patriot
yes oh this guy's served his guy
here's what i said on the podcast last
week that they laughed at me deep down i
don't think biden wants to win this
election
i don't think he wants to be president
he knows everything that's in his
background it's a house of cards
it's going to come crumbling down no one
isn't it's not
he's raised a billion and a half dollars
he's done every debate he's done
everything
okay for the last week for him not to
want to win the presidency
this just proves that people who are
going to vote for trump are going to
vote for trump and people who are going
to vote for biden are going to vote for
bodybuilding a great point
and that's that i mean i don't think why
can't you look at this as a
psychological
situation what's wrong with someone not
wanting to do something that's all i'm
saying
in his heart he would prefer not to know
what does it do for you i i i
knew your opinion i'm going to say this
much if
if he happened to have heard leslie
stahl because again
two things happened the same day i don't
think coincidence exists in this world
ever anywhere if on the same day she's
saying
there is no corroboration over and over
and over again
maybe he's throwing up his hands and
saying yes there is corruption he could
have done it that quickly i think this
had
been planned before he released this
this was everything's timing right now
if you're asking why did it come out
today it's 100
part of trump's strategy it's 100
strategic if you think
why sasha cohen's like the story has
really become big today and the video is
being released when people are watching
it
it's because giuliani was going after
you know
hunter stuff and so now they have to
undermine giuliani and they're hanging
on to it to embarrass
him and it was easy to do if if
anybody's guys for the last
two months we've all been saying the
same thing october is going to be the
dirtiest
ugliest scariest month of the year it is
nobody's surprise
can you imagine halloween when i saw the
giuliani thing i'm sitting there saying
you know by the way he went on howard
stern i don't know if you saw when he
was on howard
and they asked him about this on howard
stern they said so what do you think
about this
and and you know well you know he was
trying to get me but i told him i knew
what we're trying to do
because i've seen that guy before that
stuff may have worked before but it
doesn't work today and i knew what they
were doing then the girl who's the girl
on howard stern that's been with him for
a while what's her name
so she says well is there anything you
want to tell us that may come out later
on
you know what he said uh uh
you know i don't remember anything first
of all of course you remember as is
this is rude he's a better so you know
when this comes out it's gonna look
very very awkward uh when this thing
comes out but for me
when i see something like this and you
show me proof of communication
this is bad news when when in when the
emails of hillary were taken out
that was bad news okay that's terrible
news because
you know if if they were able to see the
emails you would it's proof you're going
to sit there and say like wikileaks
remember how much of a role that guy
played in the election last time
julian assange when new things would
come up because it's proof
it's email it's written if he can prove
it
this is going to be ugly theory the fbi
is sitting on this laptop
why are they sitting why are they
sitting on the laptop so
if he's going up in front of the senate
tomorrow with his corroborating evidence
then
the senate can say to the fbi why are
you sitting on this laptop
so i mean again we
we as the american people don't know why
the fbi is dragging their feet on this
we should know let me ask you we should
know regardless of who it's about
if it's a matter of national security
but adam
if you don't mind pat adam look bro
here's your reality behind things
anybody that goes publicly pro-trump or
anti-biden gets ruined
is that simple so it's not just from joe
blow jumping on the tv
risky his entire reputation and his
whole family you go pro-trump
and anti-biden publicly you're ruined
because the media will ruin you and that
man's face
will be played back or said or he lied
or he's lying i don't know how many
times
like there's a there's an element to
going pro trump
anti-biden right now in this day and age
today uh whatever eight o'clock or 7 50
texas time bro it's it's it's damn near
social suicide he's got something in
common
he's got something in common with trump
he and trump both gave a bunch of
democrats
right so he said that a hundred percent
but the difference between him is
trump gave to democrat and republican
trump gave to both sides he only gave to
them democrats
only big difference yeah so so i mean so
is it really just some joe blow on there
saying i have three phones and look at
this
i mean would you really recommend your
question to ask have you already made up
your mind who you're voting for yes
have you already made up your mind have
you already made up your mind have you
already made it
have you already made up your mind who
you're voting for i'm still ninety
percent
abiding okay so let me ask you this
so so i if you're watching this do you
think
adam has already made up his mind who
was voting for him
tomorrow we can get video comes out that
biden shoot somebody
sure but i could not cast my ballot okay
so then you have made up your minds
that's a difference
but she hasn't made up her mind so let's
talk to danielle so
all the undecided voters what are you
looking for to make your decision who
you're going to vote for i want to find
out who's going to talk like an adult
and tell me about the policies that
they're going to pursue
over and over again okay the the one
point that leslie
stahl scored in that interview was she
kept saying
you're saying there's an alternative to
obamacare if it gets turned over
what is it just give it to me in a few
sentences and he said i can take you
after and show you
sorry he should be able to say at this
point in one paragraph in a sound bite
as any
as any politician should be this is
exactly what i'm going to do for
healthcare in america
and this is how i'm going to do it and
i've had this many people vetting the
plan
and he should be able to put it in three
or four sentences or in two minutes
and you know he should be able to do
that at the exact same time joe biden
says how he's going to put an end to
antifa and uprisings throughout this
country and some of these stuff
exactly answer the questions i want to
hear substantive answers from
both of them i want to see who can
actually play the adult in the room
here's a different question for you
here's a different question for you the
different questions
the next question for you is this so
for you what are your top things you
look for when you vote
so go on number one i look for this is
it economy first
what is so if you can kind of go through
this china where are you at with you
there's a brand new poll out today
number one is the economy number two is
the coronavirus
period end what is it for you same thing
okay got it
same things i i'm i tend to be with the
average american
we've had two days with a thousand
deaths i mean
let me tell you what they do on twitter
if you talk about cases rising people
like
it's a hoax i'm like fine fine we'll
just we'll leave it to fatalities
we'll wait until hospitalizations are
going up which they are in wisconsin
in michigan a lot of swing states right
now as it gets colder
but but people want to know what's the
future
for the economy and what's the future
for the chronovirus nobody wants to shut
down again
but they they want to know what the
leader's plan is
if we're not shutting down how are you
going to make sure my small business
stays open
virus question that's an economy
question
25th on my list of things
coronavirus
you're looking at this the wrong way i'm
speaking on behalf of the 25
of american businesses small businesses
that are closing
because the people who frequent their
businesses are afraid to come out of
their homes because there's no cohesive
policy
it's it's not okay but there's two sides
to that are they freaked out by the
message that they're getting constantly
no they don't know we're talking about
that everybody knows this
i'll probably figure out a dead body hey
look i live in california it's all a
scam
as far as what gavin newsom is doing as
far as shutting down disneyland shutting
down universal studios
destroying anaheim destroying orange
that is that is to the absolute extreme
and he's
the most guilty for putting small
businesses out of business permanently
i want for a politician to tell me how
they're going to keep it safe for me to
keep my business
not how they're going to shut me down
and keep you shut down what's happening
to california is ridiculous
i mean they should be they should be
putting up a wall at the border because
these people are leaving california
in the droves danielle question i want
you to give two grades
trump's handling of the economy trump's
handling of the coronavirus what would
you grade trump
i would say she's an economist here so i
would say that his handling of the
economy has been
a solid b solid b for trump solid b
i would say that his handling of the
coronavirus has been a solid see
he keeps falling back on fouchy and
saying
but he said not to wear mass and then he
changed his mind you want a leader who's
like
wait a minute i've got this the epiphany
the light bulb goes off
i can think for myself i can do my own
homework
and i can come out with my i don't have
to rely on somebody
to tell me what my policy should be i am
the leader of the free world
i can figure it out on my own you can't
say that okay so let's just say you say
you can say that
but it it's tough to say that and then
on the other side
when he does it on the military side you
said what do you know about military you
can't make a decision for these guys
have been awarded you have been divorced
so it's either
you can take that position but you also
have to say
you ought to listen to the military you
ought to listen to fouchy or you got to
take the position saying no you're the
commander-in-chief you don't listen to
the generals you may you do the research
you make the decision you don't listen
to your you know leader that spouse
if somebody says and this is this is the
fatal flaw of any economist
if if the facts change and you keep your
bias
you're going to go down with the ship so
if the facts changed
and you don't change your mind there's
then that just means you're too rigid in
your thinking
sure sure but but also if you go to it
and maybe maybe he discounts what fouch
he thought
that's fine maybe he moves on and gets
himself a new expert
who knows if he's like well this guy's
waffling he's going back and forth last
week it was no mass this week's it's
this mask
maybe i'll go find somebody who's
objective who i can look to to new and
different scientific guidance from but
if you look if you look at the beginning
of the state
like if you look back from when he
started to be president i i i put myself
when i'm gonna speak
i put myself in a position like for
example with trump right
he's been attacked for how many years
right so when they say hey this coronal
thing is gonna come in
possible in the economy was it a good
idea for him to say it was a hoax
no but when you're always attacked you
have to us
and it's not the smartest thing to do as
a president you have to assume that
you're just getting attacked again
but let's move away from that which i
don't agree that he did that but if we
look at february and march in february
because i'm from california
um pelosi was a [ __ ] city which is san
francisco telling everybody
come out it's okay we're good
everything's under control come visit us
and that needs to be played over and
over
it's not and there's so many cuomo said
we want to thank the president he's
doing a good job
he said that the the president of uh
arizona
i mean the governor of arizona governor
every governor said he's doing a great
job
he's doing as best as he can thank you
why aren't they playing these videos
they accuse him of it's a hoax it's your
fault everybody's dying but yet
every single democrat including pelosi
the house speaker
she was in san francisco in the middle
of the city february 28 saying
we're good
no but why did it become a political
issue because the democrats can use it
to try to get trump but i want to hear
what you said why did it become a
political i don't think it no i i think
it became a political issue because
the politicization of the mask itself is
at trump's feet
no no that's not the question why did it
become a political issue because trump
made it one
so it's trump made it a political issue
in my view
tell me why look nancy pelosi should
have never been in chinatown saying
come on out at that point trump himself
should have come out and said
that's reckless and he should have
called her out and stuck with it but
instead he's waffled
back and forth you heard the 60 minutes
interview today
i don't know about mass they might be
good they might they might possibly be
bad they might but it's
if i'm leaning on an expert fauci who
changes his mind
every other day who the hell do i listen
to does he
do do you keep a close manager next to
you if you find out
that he's wrong tasks don't work in
march then you tell me it works then you
tell me this then you don't wear a mess
then you're fouchy
you're at a washington national game
sitting in the middle of two people and
you're not wearing a mask oh but
you took a test but you don't know if
they took a test danielle there is
so much hypocrisy i understand what they
did the media to spin this thing into
political thing
to do whatever they can to hurt the
economy because they knew one thing you
know how this thing works
if economy is good if the president's
obama if the president's bush
if the president's clinton we're going
to do it two terms if the economy is bad
they're not banned
if there is if if if we don't shut down
the economy i want to ask this question
if we don't shut down the economy and
the approach was taken in a different
way
dow today's at 35. what is the chances
of biting him and having a chance to win
80 20. it's not right it would win the
stock market
yeah that's what i'm saying to you yeah
so what i'm
just it's because they turn it into
political things look at california
florida
disneyland against disney world same
company two different states one of them
let's go
it doesn't open up the uh park for 200
days the other one opens up july that
was a great opportunity
but the point i'm trying to make you is
the same company and bob iger is a
hardcore democrat
and he himself stepped out and said i'm
not doing anything with newsome they
politicized it
you can't say trump politicized it wait
wait there's no way in the world you can
say trump's criticizing
you're missing the core issue he calls
it the china virus
okay but he doesn't make the connection
to it being the china virus and saying
and saying many places in america the
economy suffered because china didn't
release the data
politicized that's not political that's
not but i'm saying he's just saying
maybe he didn't do the right thing or
maybe he didn't use the right time
many of our allies australia many of our
allies shut down because
the politicians were they were they were
in the dark because china
did not release the data when's the last
time since you've been born
you've seen the economy shut down and
nobody's going to work
pat there were there were aerial images
of the crematoriums over wuhan
everybody was scared shitless i know i'm
with you i'm not no i'm not saying
anything but
but i guess we didn't know how bad it
was because china kept all the data
so what are you supposed to do we're on
the same page here so first of all
number one enemy to me is china i fully
work on the same page when it comes down
to china to me being somebody that's
from iran if iran and china wants biden
i'm concerned
i'm concerned about that i'm concerned
about why the iran and chinese
leadership the government is excited
about biden become a president and not
trump why because you're not going to
get
who's going to be harder on china of
course trump's going to be hard on china
so for me if we're going to that
perspective i'm pure economy guys
by the way we're getting started so let
me give you the details of today's uh
debate so that was great phenomenal
everybody this was very good location
belmont university in nashville
tennessee
i've been a national tennessee shout out
to all the folks who've been to
silverado in nashville it's a great
night club they taught me how to dance
country
moderator kristen welker which we all
know is not a trump fan it's going to be
interesting how that goes she's from
msnbc
topic of debates fighting covet 19
american families
race in america climate change national
security and leadership
format the commission on presidential
debate said this week that it was
changing on debate rules so that each
candidate
will be silenced while the other gives a
two-minute opening statement at the
start of each 15-minute segment during
the rest of the discussion in each
block having said that i think we're
getting close to it
uh one quick question yes do the words
hunter biden get mentioned in the first
30 minutes
by trump yes by anyone other than trump
i don't know well something came to
light today
there was a press conference an hour ago
mr biden did you see that have you have
any comments she will fall back on the
fact that until then
until the evidence is made public peace
right now why don't you put it up the
way don't know what to say
start showing it that work no no meaning
in the screen okay good so they can see
that
do you have any opinions pat on how this
is going to turn out tonight i think
it's going to be uglier than the first
one i don't think it's going to be
is that possible yeah i think it's going
to be uglier than the first one because
imagine today what their day looks like
with all these different stories
and in your brain you're trying to find
out what angle at least everyone's
giving you advice
everyone's telling you what angle you
should take everyone's trying to
especially buy it and like
they've told them a million different
things on what to try to do yeah and
you're trying to get all your angles in
place so all this week that biden's been
preparing
it's irrelevant because five different
events happen today yeah
so whatever you've been preparing for
put it out there what does trump need to
do in order to win this debate and what
is biden trump's got to be trump trump's
got to be trump
stay with the facts yeah and biden's got
to try to get away from the stories as
much as possible i'm interested to see
that she
look at her she's ready to crush trump
oh she just parked up her eyebrows
by the way the human element with biden
is what i'm going to watch for this is
his family that's involved it's not just
policy in the country
this is one of his sons is dead yeah the
other one's alive
and is the villain of the u.s right now
so she's a latina right
cheers yes i just want everybody now
watching this on behalf of the latino
community
we do not support that woman she hasn't
even started yet bro
all right so bias right there right now
he's not biased i don't know what she
stands for what did she stand for like
you were talking about what does she
stand for look
she's anti-trump okay okay so you know
daddy was making some interesting points
earlier she says i want to know what
he's going to do
here's the reality i go off of history
because history always repeats itself
what it was
winston churchill said he says in order
for in order for us to look at the
future we have to go look deep in the
past
47 years what has been done he's done
the crime bill 1993 and mass
incarcerated blacks
right you know here's the last thing uh
memorizing his lines
okay guys let's have a good debate bring
it in and i welcome you to the final
2020 presidential debate
tonight's debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
it is conducted under health and safety
can we turn that up a little designed
by the commission's health security
advisor the audience here in the hall
has promised to remain silent
no cheers boos or other interruptions
except
right now as we welcome to the stage
former vice president joe biden
and president donald j trump
no matthew oh my god
oh lord number some of my what a
responsible name
this debate will cover six major topics
at the beginning of each section each
candidate will have two minutes
uninterrupted to answer my first
question the debate commission will then
turn on their microphone only when it is
their time
put us on the bottom exactly when the
two the commission
fire after that both microphones will
remain on
but on behalf of the voters i'm going to
ask you to please speak one at a time
the goal is for you to hear each other
and for the american people to hear
every word of what you both have to say
and so with that if you're ready let's
start
and we will begin with the fight against
the coronavirus president trump the
first question is for you
the country is heading into a dangerous
new phase more than 40
000 americans are in the hospital
tonight with covid including record
numbers here in tennessee
and since the two of you last shared a
stage sixteen thousand americans have
died from covid
so please be specific how would you lead
the country during this
next stage of the coronavirus crisis two
minutes uninterrupted
so as you know 2.2 million people
modeled out were expected to die we
closed up
the greatest economy in the world in
order to fight
this horrible disease that came from
china it's a worldwide pandemic
it's all over the world you see the
spikes in europe and many other places
right now
if you notice the mortality rate is down
85 percent uh the excess mortality rate
is way down and much lower than almost
any other country
and we're fighting it and fighting it
hard there is a spike there was a spike
it was a very big spike in texas it's
now gone there was a very big spike in
arizona it's now gone
and there are some spikes and surges and
other places they will soon be gone
we have a vaccine that's coming it's
ready it's
going to be announced within weeks it's
going to be delivered we have
operation warp speed which is the
military is going to distribute the
vaccine
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call it some people
could say it was a cure but
i was in for a short period of time and
i got better very fast or i wouldn't be
here tonight
and now they say i'm immune whether it's
four months or a lifetime nobody's been
able to say that but
i'm immune more and more people are
getting better we have a problem that's
a worldwide problem this is a
worldwide problem but i've been
congratulated by the heads of many
countries
on what we've been able to do with the
if you if you take a look at what we've
done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else
and in particular ventilators we're now
making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them all
over the world
it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner it's going away
okay former vice president biden to you
how would you lead the country out of
this crisis
you have two minutes uninterrupted 220
americans dead if you hear nothing else
i say tonight
hear this anyone who's responsible for
not taking
control in fact not saying i'm
i take no responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths
should not remain as president of the
united states
like we're in a situation where there
are a thousand
deaths a day right a thousand deaths a
day
and there are over 70 000 new
cases per day compared to
what's going on in europe as the new
england medical journal said they're
starting from a very
low rate we're starting from very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
000 americans dead be timed between now
and the end of the year
if we just wore these masks the
president's own advisors have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
what i would do is make sure we have
everyone encouraged to wear a mask
all the time i would make sure we move
in the direction of rapid testing
investing in
rapid testing i would make sure that we
set up national standards as to how to
open up
schools and open up businesses so they
can be safe and give them the
wherewithal the financial resources to
be able to do that
we're in a situation now where the new
england medical journal one of the
serious most serious journals in the
in the whole world said for the first
time ever that this the way this
president has responded to this crisis
has been absolutely tragic and so folks
i will take care of this i will end this
i will make sure we have a plan it's
almost comical president trump i'd like
to
follow up with you and your comments you
talked about taking a therapeutic i
assume you're referencing
regeneron you also said a vaccine will
be coming within weeks
is that a guarantee is no it's not a
guarantee but it will be by the end of
the year but i think it has a good
chance there are two companies i think
within a matter of weeks
and it will be distributed very quickly
you tell us which companies
johnson johnson is doing very well
moderner is doing very well
pfizer's doing very well and we have
numerous others
then we also have others that we're
working on very closely with other
countries in particular europe
let me follow up with you because this
is new information
that's coming soon give
is
that's the head of logistics and this is
a very easy distribution for him he's
ready to go as soon as we have the
vaccine
and we expect to have 100 million vials
as soon as we have the vaccine
he's ready to go vice president biden
your reaction and just 40
percent of americans say they would
definitely agree to take a coronavirus
vaccine
if it was approved by the government
what steps would you take to give
americans confidence
in a vaccine if it were approved make
sure it's totally
transparent have the scientists the
world see it
know it look at it go through all the
processes and by the way
he's this is the same fellow who told
you this is going to end by easter last
time
it's the same fella who told you that
don't worry we're going to end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter a dark winter
and he has no clear plan and there's no
prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plan i have a dark winter
and
at all we're opening up our country
we've learned and studied and understand
the disease
which we didn't at the beginning when i
closed and banned
china from coming in heavily infected
and then ultimately europe
but china was in january months later he
was saying i was xenophobic i did it too
soon now he's saying oh
i should have i should have you know
moved quicker but he didn't move quicker
he was months behind me
many months behind me and frankly he ran
the h1
n1 swine flu and it was a total disaster
far
less lethal but it was a total disaster
had that had this kind of numbers
700 000 people would be dead right now
but it was a far less lethal disease
look his own person who ran that for
him who as you know was his uh chief of
staff
said it was catastrophic it was horrible
we didn't know what we were doing now he
comes up and he tells us how to do this
also everything that he said about the
way every single move that he said we
should make
that's what we've done we've done all of
it but he was way behind us
vice president biden your response my
response is he is xenophobic but not
because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source was
what did the president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china has been
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
and and then what happened was we
started talking about using the defense
act
to make sure we go out and get whatever
is needed out there to protect people
and again i go back to this he had
nothing he did
virtually nothing and then he gets out
of the hospital
and he talks about where this is oh
don't worry
it's all going to be over soon come on
there's not another serious scientist in
the world who thinks it's going to be
over soon
president trump your reaction over soon
i say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he is he has the ability to
lock himself
up he's obviously made a lot of money
someplace but he has this
thing about living in a basement people
can't do that by the way i
as the president couldn't do that i'd
love to put myself in the basement or in
a beautiful room in the white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
and kirsten every every meeting i had
every meeting i had and i'd meet a lot
of families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i hated it does
the guy have an snl dude
i said you know this is dangerous and
you catch it and you know i caught it i
learned a lot
i learned a lot great doctors great
hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nature we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation
and of course the cdc has said young
people can get a great start to the
debate
just so you know what's actually true
these are two adults so far and she's
letting them talk
i actually like the way she's doing it
30 seconds of refresher no number one i
know ricky's
saying you know he's already okay we're
learning to live with professionals
people are learning to die with him you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over and trying to touch
their
out of habit where their wife her
husband was is gone
learning to live with it come on we're
dying with it
because he's never said he said it's
dangerous
when's the last time is it really
dangerous still are we dangerous you
tell the people it's dangerous now
what should they do about the danger and
you say i take no responsibility
let me talk about your excuse me i think
i take full responsibility
it's not my fault that he came here it's
china's fault
and you know what it's not joe's fault
that it came here either it's china's
fault
they kept it from going into the rest of
china for the most part
but they didn't keep it from coming out
to the world
when we knew it was coming when it hit
what happened
what did the president say he said don't
worry it's going to go away
be gone by easter don't worry the warm
weather don't worry maybe inject
he did say that he said i'll be in
eastern church services he said that
the whole range of things the president
has said even today
he thinks we are by this point there are
a thousand people dying every day right
now we're back up to that level
it's it's serious for their families
perhaps fully believe all that data
some of that data has been proven to not
be true and i know for a fact
if you just study excess mortality it
takes it all out of the wash
and that went on for months nancy pelosi
said the same thing she was dancing on
the streets in chinatown in san
francisco
but when i closed he said this is a
terrible thing you xenophobic i think he
called me racist even
and because i was closing it to china
now he says i should have closed it
earlier
it just joe it doesn't work i didn't say
either of those things you certainly
shouldn't
i talked about a xenophobia in a
different context it wasn't about
closing the border to chinese oh my god
i want to talk about both of your
different strategies to handle i thought
i shouldn't have closed the border
that's obvious
is that do you want to respond to that
quickly vice president okay
it what do you say to americans who are
fearful that the cost of shutdowns the
impact on the economy
the higher rates of hunger depression
domestic and substance abuse outweighs
the risk of exposure to the body that's
so true what i would say is going to
just know the first question the country
it's his ineptitude the cause that
caused the country to have to shut down
in large part
why businesses have gone underway
people have lost their living and why
they're concerned those other concerns
are real that's why
he should have been instead of in a sand
trap in his golf course he should have
been negotiating
with nancy pelosi and the rest of the
democrats and republicans about
what to do about the accident there was
no big cheer here
there were cheers in some houses in
america right now
shut down just saying he plays a lot of
golf i'm not shutting you down tonight
but there are
look they need standards the standard is
if you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everybody
says slow up
more social distancing do not open bars
and do not open gymnasiums
do not open until you get this under
control under more control
but when you do open give the people the
capacity to be able to open and have the
capacity
to do it safely for example schools
schools they need a lot of money to
program they need to
deal with ventilation systems they need
to deal with smaller classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money
or at least up to now let's talk about
schools president trump i think we have
to respond if i might
please and then i have a follow-up thank
you and i appreciate that look all he
does is talk about civil rights but
forget about him
his democrat governors cuomo in new york
you look at what's going on in
california
you look at pennsylvania north carolina
democrats democrats all
they're shut down so tight and they're
dying
they're dying and he supports all these
people
all he talks about is shutdowns no we're
not going to shut down
and we have to open our schools and it's
like as an example
i have a young son he also tested
positive
by the time i spoke to the doctor the
second time he was fine it just went
away
young people i guess it's their immune
system let me follow up with you
president trump you've demanded schools
open in person and insist they can do it
safely but just yesterday
boston became the latest city to move
its public school system entirely online
after a coronavirus spike
what is your message to parents who
worry that sending their children to
school will endanger not only their kids
but also their teachers and families i
want to open the schools
the transmittal rate to the teachers is
very small but i want to open the
schools we have to open our country
we're not going to have a country
you can't do this we can't keep this
country close this is a
massive country with a massive economy
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself that's what's
happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
vice president biden you're simply not
true
we ought to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
safely
open but would they need resources to
open
you need to be able to for example if
you're going to open a business
have social distancing within the
business you need to have if you have a
restaurant you need to have
plexiglas dividers so people cannot
infect one another you need to be in a
position where you can take
testing rapidly and know whether a
person is
in fact infected you need to be able to
trace you need to be able to provide
all the resources that are needed to do
this and that is not inconsistent with
saying that what we're going to make
sure that we open safely and by the way
he just scored a point i'm sorry not
that many people
were doing this there's social
differencing in restaurants all that
stuff is already happening
that's all that was three months ago
when we even have department of health
and services come to our office
it's a ghost town say you want to talk
about lexington
the guy's not sleepy he's not dementia
he's out there talking point to point
with trump putting them
to even debate right now nobody's
winning right no one's even right now
disagreements
i mean my husband's got a salesman he's
45 year old marathon runner
his kid got the coronavirus i mean
marathon runner buff guy look at new
york and what's happened to mike two
weeks in the hospital
daniel died my wife's entire family got
corona
her mom her stepdad her sister her two
nieces
they were bored after one day because
they wanted to get out that's what i'm
saying it's random i mean this 45 year
old marathon runner lands in the
hospital for two weeks he must have had
some sort of other
no he wasn't there for coronavirus it's
random that's the problem with this
thing
it's random ricky you have the grown up
for hollows
i like the flu money's
new york has lost more than 40 000
people 11 000 people in nursing homes
say spike
take a look at what's happening in
pennsylvania
where they've had it closed take a look
at what's happening with your friend
in michigan where her husband's the only
one allowed to do anything
it's been like a prison now it was just
ruled unconstitutional
take a look at north carolina they're
having spikes
and they've been closed and they're
getting killed financially
we can't let that happen joe you can't
let that happen
we have to open up and we understand the
disease we have to protect our seniors
we have to protect our elderly
we have to protect especially our
seniors with heart problems and
diabetes problems and we will protect we
have the best testing in the world by
far
that's why we have so many cases let me
follow up with you before we move on to
our next section president trump this
week we call dr anthony though
the nation's best known infectious
disease expert quote she said the
foundation
you described him and other medical
experts as quote idiots
if you're not listening to them who are
you listening to i'm listening to all of
them including anthony i get along very
well with anthony but
he did say don't wear masks he did say
as you know this is not going to be a
problem
i think he's a democrat but that's okay
he said this is not going to be a
problem
we are not going to have a problem at
all when joe says that
i said anthony fauci said and others and
many others and i'm not
knocking him a lot nobody knew look
nobody knew what this thing was nobody
knew where it was coming from what it
was
we've learned a lot but anthony said
don't wear masks now he wants to wear
masks
anthony also said if you look back exact
words here's his exact question
this is no problem this is going to go
away soon so he's allowed to make
mistakes
he happens to be a good person vice
president biden your response quickly
and then we're going to move on to the
next section our response is that
think about what the president knew in
january and didn't tell the american
people
he was told this was a serious virus
that spread in the air
and it was much worse than much worse
than the flu
he went on record he just got mad for
the first time
recorded that in fact he knew how
dangerous it was but he didn't
unfortunately he's on tape with bob
woodward saying it but guess what
in the meantime we find out in the new
year that's why trump just got mad for
the first time
his folks went to wall street and said
this is a really dangerous thing
and the memo out of that meeting not
from his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short because we got to get moving
it's a dangerous problem well this is
i'm going to give you 30 seconds to
respond and then we're going to the wall
street
i don't know somebody went the wall
street you're the one that takes all the
money from wall street i don't take it
all right you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals
have made you know i could raise so much
more money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the heads of every company in america
they're all they're all at least he's
not naming names so exxon mobil doesn't
have to come out with another advisory
wall street you shouldn't be bringing up
wall street because you're the one that
takes the money from wall street not me
i could blow away your records that like
you wouldn't believe we don't need money
we have plenty of money in fact
we beat hillary clinton with a tiny
fraction of the money that's used
all right gentlemen don't tell me about
average contribution 43
all right we're going to move on to our
next section which is national security
and i do want to start with the security
of our elections and some breaking news
from overnight just last night
top intelligence officials confirmed
again that both russia and iran
are working to influence this election
both countries have obtained u.s voter
registration information these officials
say
and iran sent intimidating messages to
florida voters
this question goes to you mr vice
president what would you do to put an
end to this threat you have
two minutes uninterrupted i made it
clear
and i ask everyone else to take the
pledge i made it clear that any country
no matter who it is that interferes in
american elections will
pay a price they will pay a price
it's been overwhelmingly clear this
election i won't get into the last one
this election that russia has been
involved china has been involved to some
degree and now we learn
that that that iran is involved
they will pay a price if i'm elected
they're interfering with americans
what's the price that's what's going on
right now with american
sovereignty and to the best of my
knowledge i don't think the president
said anything to putin about it
i don't think he said a word i don't
know why he hadn't said a word to putin
about it
and i don't know what he has recently
said if anything to the iranians might
see now he's deflecting he's not saying
what he would do not hear what he said
to the iranians about a week and a half
ago
the hell that they would face if there
was she's he's accusing him of
not standing up to these foreign but
he's accusing him instead of saying what
he would do what is happening with his
buddy
well i won't i shouldn't oh i will his
buddy rudy giuliani
he's being used as a russian pawn he's
being fed in
open that door that is russian wow that
was out of nowhere
what happened that
he should not have done it first about
russia is wanting to do this
because they know they know them and
they know
me i don't understand why this president
is unwilling to take on putin
when he's actually paying bounties to
kill american soldiers in afghanistan
when he's engaged in activities that are
trying to destabilize all of
nato i don't know why he doesn't do it
but it's worth
asking the question he's gonna
president trump same question to you let
me let me ask a question you're gonna
have two minutes to respond for two
elections in a row now there has been
substantial interference from foreign
adversaries
what would you do in your next term to
put an end to this two minutes
let me respond to the first part as joe
answered
joe got three and a half million dollars
from russia and it came through putin
because he was very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of
moscow's wife and you've got three and a
half million
families and you know someday you're
gonna have to explain
why did you get three to half i never
got any money from russia i don't get
money from russia
now about your thing last night i knew a
little bit a lot of money from china
through john who was john ratliff who
was fantastic dna
he said the one thing that's common to
both of them
they both want you to lose because there
has been nobody tougher to russia
with between the sanctions nobody
tougher than me on russia
between the sanctions between all of
what i've done with nato you know i've
got the nato countries to put up
an extra 130 billion going to 420
billion dollars a year
that's to guard against russia i sold
while he was selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher than on russia than donald trump
and i'll tell you they were so bad they
took over the
the submarine port you remember that
very well
during your term during you and barack
obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia they were paying you a lot of
money
and they probably still are but now with
what came out today
it's even worse all of the emails the
emails the horrible emails of the kind
of money that you were raking in you and
your family
and joe you were vice president when
some of this was happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
ago who was essentially supposed to work
with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it right now
vice president biden you may respond
on the election security i have not
taken a penny from any foreign source
ever in my life we learned that this
president
has a secret bank account with china
does
business in china and in fact is talking
about me taking money
i have not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns
22 years go look at them 22 years of my
tax return
you have not released the single
solitary year of your tax return
why are you unwilling the foreign
countries are paying you
a lot russia's paying you a lot china's
painting a lot on your hotels and all
your businesses all around the country
all around the world and china's
building a new road to a new
a golf course you have overseas so
what's going on here why don't release
your tax return or stop talking about
corruption
president trump your response first of
all i called my accountants
underwrote it i'm going to release them
as soon as we can i want to do it and
show how successful how great this
company is but
much more important than that people
were saying 750
i asked them a week ago i said what did
i pay
they said sir you prepaid tens of
millions of dollars i prepaid my tax
tens over the last number of years tens
of millions of dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that did your account nobody told you
that
excuse me and it wasn't written whenever
they write this they keep talking about
which i think is a filing fee but let me
just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give 10 percent
to the big man you're the big man i
think i don't know maybe you're not
but you're the big man i thank god you
sense that we have to give ten percent
to the big men
what do you mean joe what's that all
about it's terrifying gentlemen i want
to ask you both some questions
they're just they're goating each other
respond very quickly
about potentially releasing your taxes
did he tell you when you can release
them do you
how big is the deadline for when you're
going to release it i get there he did
worse than the tea party got treated
because i have a lot of people in there
deep down in the irs they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until i decided to run for
president
i get treated very badly by the irs very
unfairly
but we had a deal all done as soon as
we're completed with the deal i want to
release it
but i have paid millions and millions of
dollars and i
it's worse than paying i paid in advance
it's called prepaying your taxes i paid
it
we got the prepaid part both about
questions
do you believe them on the tax thing i
have been raised
i do not know the law because this has
never occurred before whether or not
the statute of limitations goes on hold
as long as he's in office
stop playing around you've been saying
for four years you're gonna release your
taxes
nobody knows mr president what they do
know is you're not
paying your taxes or you're paying taxes
that are so
low when last time he said what he paid
he said
i only pay that little because i'm smart
i know how to game the system
come on come on folks so president trump
and then i want to get to two questions
to both of you
i was put through a phony witch hunt oh
boy
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied on
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through let me just
say this mueller and 18
angry democrats and fbi agents all over
the place
spent 48 million dollars they went
through everything i had
including my tax returns and they found
absolutely no collusion and nothing
wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spend 1
million
on youtube i could find plenty wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done
and the kind of monies that your family
has taken i mean your brother made money
in iraq
millions of dollars your other brother
made a fortune
and it's all through you joe and they
say you get some of it and you do live
very well you have houses all over the
place you live very well all right
gentlemen let me just ask
some questions about all of this broadly
there have been questions about the work
your son has done in china
and for a ukrainian energy company when
you were vice president in retrospect
was anything about those relationships
inappropriate or another job
nothing was unethical here's what the
deal
with regard to ukraine we had this whole
question about whether or not because he
was on the board i later learned of a
barisma
a company that somehow i had done
something wrong
yet every single solitary person when he
was going through his impeachment
testifying under oath who worked for him
said i did my job
impeccably i carried out u.s policy
not one single solitary thing was out of
line
not a single thing number one number two
the guy who got in trouble in ukraine
was this guy trying to
bribe the ukrainian government to say
something negative about me
which they would not do and did not do
because it never
ever ever happened my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about uh
what are you talking about
china i have not had the only guy who
made money from china
is this guy he's the only one nobody
else has made money from china
you definitely don't do it let me ask my
question to you
but could i just one terrible reason
because his son
didn't have a job for a long time was
sadly no longer in
the military service i won't get into
that and he didn't have a job
as soon as he became vice president
barisma not the best look
not the best reputation in the world i
hear they paid him 183
000 a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a three million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm gonna let the vice president
for that everybody investigated that no
one said anything he did was wrong in
ukraine
okay president trump this is for you
since you took office you've never
divested from your business why were
they so quick on that they didn't spend
a lot of time
a report this week which was referenced
does indicate that your company has a
bank account in china
so how can voters know that you don't
have any foreign conflicts of interest
i have many bank accounts and they're
all listed and they're all over the
place i mean
i was a businessman doing business the
banker tested by the new york times
we've never really anybody knows about
it it's listed the bank account was in
2013. that's what it was it was open to
do
it was closed in 2015 i believe
and then i decided because i was going
to do i was thinking about doing a deal
in china like
millions of other people i was thinking
about it and i decided i'm not going to
do it
didn't like it i decided not to do it
had an account open
and i'd close it okay excuse me and then
unlike him where his vice president and
he does business
i then decided to run for president
after that that was before
so i closed it before i even ran for
president
let alone became president big
difference he is
the vice president of the united states
and his son his brother
and his other brother are getting rich
they're like a vacuum cleaner they're
sucking
i do want to ask you uh vice president
biden about
china let's talk about china more
broadly there have
of course president trump has said that
they should pay for
not being fully transparent in regards
to the corona virus
if you were president would you make
china pay and please be specific what
would that look like thank you what i'd
make china do is play by the
international rules
not like he has he has caused the
deficit in china to go up not down
with china that's true we're making sure
that
in order to do business in china you
have to give all your intellectual
property you have to
have a partner in china 51 we would not
do that at all
number one number two we're in a
situation where china would have to play
by the rules internationally as well
when i met with xi that and uh when i
was still vice president he said we're
setting up air identification zones in
the
in the south china sea you can't fly
through them i said we're going to fly
through them we just flew b-52
b-1 bombers through it we're not going
to pay attention they have to play
by the rules and what's he do he
embraces
guys like the thugs like in north korea
and
and uh and the chinese president and
putin and others
and he pokes his fingers now all of our
friends all of our allies
we make up only 25
25 of the world's economy we need to be
having the rest of our friends
with us these are the rules you play by
them or you're going to pay the price
for not paying by them
economically that's the way i will run
it and that's what we did
but for eight years under obama china
was never vice president never paid the
price
talk about norway plenty of evidence
respond to that
okay very quickly and a half dollars
from chinatown
after spending ten minutes in office and
being in air force two
number one number two there's a very
strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump on china
policy though what
are you going to do what specifically
are you going to do to me she's doing
good you've said she's not doing that
she's protecting millions as she raises
her voice
28 billion and you know what they did to
pay a job they devalued their currency
and they also paid out
and you know who got the money our
farmers are great farmers because they
were targeted
you never charged them anything also you
wanted to charge
us stronger than it's been in years
chinese stock market
since 1996 yesterday okay
vice president biden your response
please our response is look
this isn't about there's a reason why
he's
bringing up all this malarkey there's a
reason
he doesn't want to talk about these the
substantive issues it's not about his
family and my family
it's about your family and your family's
hurting badly
if you're making less than if you're a
middle-class family
you're getting hurt badly right now
you're sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding well we can't get new
tires
because we have to wait another month
very good deflector we're gonna be able
to pay the mortgage
neither of them have said what they're
gonna do to china neither community
college correct they're the decisions
you're making
they're just wasted wasted air time
years of experience
he's not focused on the right issues ten
seconds mr president that's a technical
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about not a difficult
politician okay
that's why i got elected let's get off
the subject of china let's talk around
sitting around the table
come on joe you can do better we're
going to talk about
the fact that there hasn't been a war or
a long-range missile test
and yet north korea recently rolled out
its biggest ever intercontinental
ballistic missile
and continues to develop its nuclear
arsenal do you see that as a betrayal of
the relationship you towards
just 30 seconds here because we need to
get on to the next so when i met with
barack
obama we sat in the white house right at
the beginning had a great conversation
was supposed to be 15 minutes and it was
well over an hour
he said the biggest problem we have with
north is north korea
he indicated we will be in a war with
north korea guess what
it would be a nuclear war and he does
have plenty of nuclear capability
in the meantime i have a very good
relationship with him different kind of
a guy but he probably thinks the same
thing about me
we have a different kind of a
relationship we have a very good
relationship
and there's no war and you know about
two months ago
he broke into a certain area they said
oh there's going to be trouble he said
no they're not
because he's not going to do that and i
was right look instead of being in a war
where millions of people
sold you know is 25 miles away millions
and millions 32 million people and so
millions of people would be dead right
now president trump that's 30 seconds
vice president biden to you north korea
conducted four nuclear tests under the
obama administration
why do you think you would be able to
reign in this persistent threat because
i'd make it clear which we were making
clear to china they had to be part of
the deal because here's the re
i made it clear and as a spokesperson in
the administration when i went to china
that they said why are you moving your
missile defense up so close why are you
moving more forces here why you continue
to do
military maneuvers with south korea i
said because
north korea is a problem and we're going
to continue to do it so we can control
them
we're going to make sure we can control
them and make sure they cannot hurt us
and so if you want to do something about
it step up and help if not
it's going to continue what has he done
he's legitimized north korea
he's talked about his good buddy who's a
thug a thug
and he talks about how we're better off
and they are have much more capable
missiles
able to reach u.s territory much more
easily than ever did before let me
follow up with you
vice president biden you've said you
wouldn't meet with kim jong-un without
preconditions are there any conditions
under which you would meet with him
on the condition that he would agree
that he would be drawing down his
nuclear capacity to get that the korean
peninsula should be nuclear free zone
all right let's move on to american
family
they tried to meet with him he wouldn't
do it he didn't like
obama he didn't like him he wouldn't do
it okay gotta give him a big truck
respond to that he wouldn't
do it and that's okay you know what
north korea
we're not in a war we have a good
relationship you know people understand
having a good relationship with leaders
of other countries
we have a lot of questions to get to
know and we had a good relationship with
hitler before he in fact invaded europe
the rest of europe come on the reason he
would not meet with
president obama is because president
obama said we're going to talk about
denuclearization
we're not going to legitimize you we're
going to continue to put stronger and
stronger
sanctions on you that's why he wouldn't
meet with us
all right and it didn't work
chris president trump okay they left me
a mess
north korea was a mess and in fact if
you remember the first two or three
months questions tonight
it was a very dangerous period of my
first three months before we
sort of worked things out a little bit
okay there was a very they
left us a mess and obama would be i
think
the first to say it was the single
biggest problem he thought
that our country okay let's move on to
american families and the economy on
one of the issues that's most important
to them is health care as you both know
today there was a key vote on a new
supreme court justice amy coney barrett
and health care is at the center of her
confirmation fight
over 20 million americans get their
health insurance through the affordable
care act
it's headed to the supreme court and
your administration mr president is
advocating for the court to overturn it
if the supreme court does overturn that
law those 20 million americans could
lose their health insurance almost
overnight so what would you do
if those people have their health
insurance taken away you have two
minutes uninterrupted
first of all i've already done something
that nobody thought was possible
through the legislature i terminated the
individual mandate
that is the worst part of obamacare as
we call it
the individual mandate where you have to
pay a fortune for the privilege of
not having to pay for bad health
insurance i terminated
it's gone now it's in court because
obamacare is no good
but then i made a decision run it as
well as you can to my people
great people run it as well as you can i
could have gone the other route and made
everybody very unhappy
they ran it premiums are down
everything's down here's the problem
no matter how well you run it it's no
good what we'd like to do
is terminate it we have the individual
mandate
done i don't know that it's going to
work if we don't win
we will have to run it and we'll have
obamacare but it'll be better run
but it no longer is obamacare because
without the individual mandate
it's much different pre-existing
conditions will always stay
what i would like to do is a much better
health care much better
will always protect people with
pre-existing so i'd like to terminate
obamacare come up with a brand new
beautiful health care
the democrats will there's a tremendous
pressure of them and we might
okay you'll see but i think we're gonna
win the house but come up with a better
health care
always protecting people with
pre-existing conditions and one thing
very important
we have 180 million people out there
that have great
private health care far more than we're
talking about with obamacare
joe biden is going to terminate all of
those policies these are people that
love their health care people that have
been successful middle income people
been successful they have 180
million plans 180 million people
families
under what he wants to do which will
basically be socialized medicine he
won't even have a choice
they want to terminate 180 million plans
we have done an incredible job on health
care
and we're going to do even better okay
vice president biden yes this is really
good calls for building on obamacare so
my question is what is your plan
if the law is ruled unconstitutional by
the supreme court you have two minutes
uninterrupted
what i'm going to do is pass obamacare
with a public option what i'm going to
do is whatever
all it tells me to do public option is
an option that says that
if you in fact do not have the
wherewithal to be if you qualify for
medicaid
and you do not have the wherewithal then
your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's going to happen
secondly we're going to make sure we
reduce the premiums and reduce drug
prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight
for with 20 candidates for the
nomination was
i support private insurance that's why i
did
not one single person with private
insurance would lose their insurance
under my plan nor did they under
obamacare
they did not lose their insurance unless
they chose they wanted to go to
something else
lastly we're going to make sure we're in
a situation that
we've actually protect pre-existing
there's no way he can protect
pre-existing conditions
none zero you can't do it in the ether
he's been talking about this for a long
time there is no he's never come up with
a plan i guess we're going to get
the pre-existing condition planned the
same time we get the infrastructure plan
that we're waiting since 17 18 19 and
20.
the fact i still have a few more minutes
i know you're getting anxious
the fact is that he's already cost the
american people because of his terrible
handling of the coven virus and economic
spillover
10 million people have lost their
private insurance
and he wants to take away 22 million
more people who have it on obamacare
and over 110 million people with
pre-existing conditions
and all the people from covet are going
to have pre-existing conditions
what are they going to do i have a
follow-up for you vice president biden
that was his first that was his best two
minutes yes he's
your health care plan which includes a
government insurance option takes the
country
one step closer to a health care system
run entirely by the government
i say it's ridiculous it's like saying
that you know
we're uh the idea that the fact that
there's a public option that people can
choose
that makes it a socialist plan look the
difference between the president i think
health care is not a
privilege it's a right everyone should
have the right to have affordable health
care
and i am very proud of my plan it's
gotten endorsed by
all the major labor unions as well as as
well as a whole range of other people
who in fact are concerned in the medical
field
this is something that's going to save
people's lives and this is going to give
some
people an opportunity an opportunity to
have health care for their children
how many of you home are worried and
rolling around in bed tonight wondering
what in god's name you're going to do if
you get sick of you because you lost
your
home insurance your your health
insurance your company's gone under
we have to provide health insurance for
people at an affordable rate and that's
what i do
president trump he was there for 47
years he didn't do it
he was now there as vice president for
eight years and it's not like it was 25
years ago it was
three and three quarters it was just a
little while ago right
less than four years ago he didn't do
anything he didn't do it
he wants socialized medicine and it's
not that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders and wants it even
more bernie sanders wants it
the democrats want it you're going to
have socialized medicine just like you
with fracking we're not going to have
fracking we're going to stop fracking
we're going to stop fracking then he
goes to pennsylvania after he gets a
nomination where he got very lucky to
get it
and he goes to pennsylvania and he says
oh we're going to have fracking
and you never ask that question and by
the way so far i respect very much the
way you're handling this i have to say
by the way but somebody should ask the
question
you can ask he goes for a year
affordable health care lower premiums
what we're going to do is going to cost
some money
it's going to cost over 700 billion
years
to do it and they're going to have lower
premiums you can buy into the better
place
the cheaper plans lower your premiums
deal with
unders unexpected billing and have your
drug prices drop
significantly he keeps talking about it
he hasn't done a
thing for anybody on health care not a
thing interesting
then i want to talk about what he says
he's talking about socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare when he
talks about a public option
he's talking about destroying your
medicare totaling district and
destroying your social security
and this whole country will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it
in his state he tried it in a state his
governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work
okay vice president obama it doesn't
mean
a very confused guy he thinks he's
running against somebody else he's
running against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
joe biden he's running against that was
actually very good that was strong
he's actually very good gonna destroy
medicare this is the guy
that the actuary medicare said if in
fact
at social security if in fact
his plan to withhold the tax on social
security
social security will be bankrupt in by
with no way to make up for it this is
the guy who's tried to cut
medicare so i don't i mean the idea that
donald trump
is lecturing me on social security and
medicare
come on he tried to get rid of he tried
to hurt social security years ago
years ago go back and look at the
records i think she wants to ask about
stimulus
talking about something in washington dc
let's get to it i have to move on to the
next question
he said we're stuck we're not gonna have
time to talk about it if i'm elected
if he's elected the stock market will
crash okay
very quickly look the idea that the
stock market is booming is his only
measure of what's happening
where i come from and scranton and claim
on that people don't live off of the
stock market
just in the uh just in the last three
and three years during this crisis
the the billionaires in this country
made according to
700 billion more dollars 700 billion
more dollars
because that's his only measure what
happens to the ordinary people out there
what happens to them let's talk about
401k
401ks are through the roof we're going
to move or through the roof
and he doesn't come from scranton that's
like one of he
lived there for a short period of time
before he even knew it for the record 45
of americans do not own stocks in any
way shape or form
55 the majority do 45
55 is a majority a majority of americans
do own stocks and people of color
they see washington fighting over a
relief bill
mr president why haven't you been able
to get them the help they need 30
seconds
because nancy pelosi doesn't want to
approach that's right i do but you're
the best that's right
i do but i still have to get
unfortunately that's one of the reasons
i think we're going to take over the
house because of her
nancy pelosi doesn't want to approve
anything because she'd love to have some
victories
on a date called november 3rd nancy
pelosi does not want to approve it
we are ready willing and able to do
something don't forget we've
already approved three plans and it's
gone through including the democrats in
all fairness
this one she doesn't want it's near the
election because she thinks it helps her
politically
i think it hurts her politically all
right mr vice president now the
republican leader in
in the united states senate said he
can't pass it he will not this is true
this is all about mcconnell it has
nothing to do with
i mean
let me ask vice president biden a
question you are the leader of the
democratic party
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get it there you go
good question i have and they have
pushed it look they passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer for three point something
trillion
no it's gigantic out there this heroes
act has been sitting there
and look at what's happening when i was
in charge of the recovery act with 800
billion
dollars i was able to get 145 billion
dollars for local communities
that have to balance their budgets and
states that have to balance the budget
so then
have to fire fire to have to fire
firefighters
teachers first responders law
enforcement officers so they can keep
their cities and counties running he
will not support that they have not
done a thing for them and mitch
mcconnell said let them go bankrupt
let them go bankrupt come on what's the
the republicans won't agree to anything
with a two-point it was a way of getting
anything trillion dollar price tag trump
said he wanted a two trillion though
well i know but he wants to get elected
money from our people's pockets
to the people that come into it well i
think he would sign it i think he would
sign two point whatever truth
i'd love to help them
but it was really a big bailout for
badly run
democrat cities and states all right if
i get elected i'm not going to i'm
running as a proud democrat but i'm
going to be an american president
i don't see red states in blue states
what i see
is america united states and folks every
single state out there
finds themselves in trouble they're
going to start lining off whether
they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because
teachers because they have to balance
their budget and the founders were smart
they allowed the federal government to
deficit spend to compensate
for the united states of america i want
to talk about the minimum wage gentlemen
mr vice president
we are talking a lot about struggling
small businesses
and business owners these days do you
think this is the right time to ask them
to raise the minimum wage you of course
support a 15
federal minimum i do because i think one
of the things we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to bail them out
too
we should be bailing them out now those
small businesses
you got one in six of them going under
they're not going to be able to make it
back
they pass the pro a package that allows
us
to be able to call ppp money's supposed
to go to help them do everything from
organize how they can deal with their
businesses being open safely
schools how they can make classrooms
smaller how they can hire more teachers
how they can put ventilation systems in
they need the help the businesses as
well as the schools need the help
but this these guys will not help them
it's not giving them
any of the money we are going to move on
to immigration okay but i want to say we
have to have
our small businesses by raising the
minimum wage that's not helping
i think it should be a state option
alabama is different than new york new
york is different from vermont
every state is different it should be a
state option you said we have to help
it's very important we have to help our
small businesses how are you helping
your small businesses when you're
forcing wages
what's going to happen and what's been
proven to happen is when you do that
these small businesses
fire many of their employees consider
raising the federal minimum wage to
fifteen dollars an hour
you said recently you would consider
raising the federal minimum wage
an hour
administration but not to a level that's
going to put all these businesses out of
business
it should be a state option look
everything in different places i know
different places they're all different
some places fifteen dollars is not so
bad
in other places other states fifteen
dollars okay president trump thank you
quick response vice president two jobs
one job
be below poverty people are making six
seven eight bucks an hour
these first responders we all clap for
as they come down the street
because they've allowed us to make it
what's happening they deserve
a minimum wage of 15 anything below that
puts you below the poverty level
and there is no evidence that when you
raise the minimum wage
businesses go out of business that is
simply not true we're going to talk
about immigration we're going to talk
about immigration now gentlemen
and we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least 4
000 kids you've since reversed your zero
tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited children are brought here
by coyotes and lots of bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into our
country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles a brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through them but how are
you reenacting
kids with their family they built cages
you know they used to say
i built the cages and then they had a
picture in a certain
newspaper and it was a picture of these
horrible cages
and they said look at these cages
president trump built them
and then it was determined they were
built in 2014
that was him yes we're working on it
very
we're trying very hard but a lot of
these kids come out without the parents
they come over through cartels and
through coyotes and through dangers
let me bring you into this conversation
quick response and then another question
to you these 500
plus kids came with parents
they separated them at the border to
make it a disincentive to come to begin
with
they real tough we're really strong and
guess what
they cannot it's not coyotes didn't
bring them over their parents
were with them they got separated from
their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let's talk about what we're talking
about what happened
parents were ripped their kids were
ripped from their arms
and separated and now they cannot find
over 500 of sets of those parents
and those kids are alone nowhere to go
joseph no way to but ricky most of these
families are from central america
let me ask you immigration from mexico
has slowed down for the past few years
i trust a personal level
well i know
if they're here to bring their children
of course happens all the time
and that's how it works and that's
exactly how they do it so to say that
i'm showing up with my kids
and we all got locked up it's [ __ ]
it's not true i don't think nobody
experiences
you're immediately certified again one
percent in this
world of course you don't know where
you're gonna leave that
even if you get across where you live
i can imagine you're five years old your
parents are taking you across
the rio grande your parents burst
and it's illegal and you say oh no mom
leave me here i'm not going to go with
you stop lying we've been here many of
your
model says over 20 000 are first
responders
out there taking care of people during
this crisis we
owe them we owe them
yes he did and i've changed without
having a
specific bro you've got to catch and
release we got rid of a lot of
horrible things that they put in and
that they lived with
but he had eight years he was vice
president he
did nothing except build cages
to keep children in vice president your
response
the catch and release you know what he's
talking about there if in fact you had
a family came across and they were
arrested
they in fact were given a date to show
up for their hearing
they were released and guess what they
showed up for a hearing
this is the first president history
united states america there's anybody
seeking asylum
has to do it in another country that's
never happened before in america
that's never happened before in america
you come to the united states and you
make your case
that i seek asylum based on the
following on the following premise why i
deserve it under american law
they're sitting in a squalor on the
other side of the river
president trump your response it just
shows that he has no
understanding of immigration of the laws
catch and release
is a disaster a murderer would come in
a rapist would come in a very bad person
we would take their name we have to
release them
into our country that's right and then
you say they come back
less than one percent of the people come
back we have to send
ice out and border patrol out to find
them yeah that is true
i would say come back in two years three
years
we're going to give you a court case you
need perry mason we're going to give you
a court case
when you say they come back they don't
come back joe they never come
back only they're really
i hate to say this but those with the
lowest iq
they might come back okay
they don't come back check it out check
it out but we don't have to worry about
it
they terminated it so we'd have to worry
about it that's right to the next yeah
525 kids not knowing where in god's name
they're going to be in london you're
going to keep using that bro
let's talk about our next section which
is racist
1500 kids they went missing
parents who feel they have no choice but
to prepare their children for the chance
that they could be targeted including by
the police
for no reason other than the color of
their skin mr vice president
in the next two minutes i want you to
speak directly to these families
do you understand why these parents here
for their children
i do i do you know my daughter
is a social worker and you're really
going to talk about this after you
create that 1999
crime bill really massive black people
one of the reasons why i ended up
working on the east side of wilmington
delaware which is
90 african-american everybody was to
learn more about what was going on what
i didn't i never had to tell my daughter
if she's pulled over make sure she puts
for a
traffic stop put both hands on top of
the wheel and don't reach for the glove
box because someone may shoot you
but a black parent no matter how wealthy
or how poor they are
has to teach their child when you're
walking down the street
don't have a hoodie on when you go
across the street making sure that you
in fact
if you get pulled over yes yes sir no
sir
hands on top of the wheel because you
are
in fact the victim whether you're a
person making
three hundred thousand three hundred
thousand dollar a year person
or someone who's on on on food stamps
the fact of the matter is there is
institutional racism america
and we have always said we've never
lived up to it that we hold these truths
to be self-evident all men and women are
created equal but guess what
we have never ever lived up to but we've
all
constantly been moving the needle
further and further to inclusion
not exclusion this is the first
president to come along and says that's
the end of that
we're not going to do that anymore we
have to provide for economic opportunity
better education
better health care better access to
schooling
better access to opportunity to borrow
money to start businesses
all the things we can do and i've laid
out because
100 billion dollars
in the first step
i would like you to speak directly to
these families do you understand
why these parents fear for their
children yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he never did a thing except in
that's right when he did such harm to
the black community
and they were called and he called them
super predators that's right
and he said that yes he did it's on
video don't lie
1994 your crime bill the super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community
than donald trump and if you look with
the exception
of abraham lincoln that's the double
exception but the acceptance
of lincoln nobody has done what i've
done
criminal justice reform obama and
joe didn't do it i don't even think they
tried because they had no chance of
doing it
they might have wanted to do it but if
you had to see the arms i had a twist to
get that done
it was not a pretty picture and
everybody knows it including some very
liberal people that
cried in my office they cried in the
oval office two weeks later they're out
saying gee we have to defeat him
criminal justice reform prison reform
opportunity zones with tim scott a great
senator from
south carolina he came in with this
incredible idea for opportunity zones
it's one of the most successful programs
hundred people don't talk about it
tremendous investment is being made
biggest beneficiary
the black and hispanic communities and
then historically black
colleges and universities ten year
program after three years of coming to
the office
i love some of those guys they were
great they came into the office
and they said i said what are you doing
after three years i said why do you keep
coming back
because we have no funding i said we
have to come back every year we have to
come back
because president obama would never give
them long-term funding
and i did 10-year long-term funding
and i gave them more money than they
asked for because they said i think you
need more
and i said the only bad part about this
is i may never see you again because
i got very friendly with them and they
like me and i like them
but i saved colleges and universities
okay
and we're going to talk about both of
your your response to that
my response to that is i never ever said
what he accused me of saying you're such
a liar
such a liar after the crime bill had
been in in
in in the law for a while this is the
guy who said
the problem with the crime bill there's
not enough people in jail there's not
enough people in jail
and go on my website get the quote the
date when he said it
not enough people we haven't talked
about you
young gangs and the people who are going
to maraude our cities
this is a guy who in the center park
five five innocent black kids he
continued to push for making sure
that they got the death penalty none of
them were none of them
were guilty of what the crimes
he wanted to put over america america we
newspaper laws which would affect more
people clearly no minimum amount
mandatories
in the law that's why i'm offering 20
billion dollars of states to change
their state laws
to eliminate minimum mandatory to do
well
no one should be going to jail because
they have a drug problem
they should be going to rehabilitation
four years ago why didn't you do that
four years ago
even less than that vice president you
keep talking about all these things
you're going to do
and you're going to do this but you were
there just a short time ago
and you guys did nothing i ran because
of you
i ran because of barack obama
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run i would have never
learned
i ran because of you i'm looking at you
now you're a politician
i ran because of you all right vice
president responds to that and
i do have some questions for both of you
i'll tell you what i uh
i hope he does look at me because what's
happening here is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character don't even know
my god
is for honor and telling the truth i am
anxious to have this race
i am anxious to see this take place i am
the character of the country is on the
ballot our characters
look at this club let me ask some
followers please respond
we're going to have toughness that's
true about russia ukraine china
other countries iraq if this is true
then he's a corrupt politician right
so don't give me the stuff about how
you're this innocent baby
joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician
president trump i want to stay on the
issue of race we're talking about
from hell president trump we're talking
about race right now and i do want to
stay
on the issue of race president trump i
have to respond to that please
look very clear there are 50 former
national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the care
four five former heads of the cia both
parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except of
his and his good friend rudy gianni you
mean the laptop is
now another russia russia russia hoax
and that's exactly what
this was exactly what this is where he's
going the
laptop is russia yeah i want to stay on
the issue of race you have to be kidding
me here we go again with
russia we're going to continue on the
issue of race mr president you've
described
the black lives matter movement as a
symbol of hate
you've shared a video of a man chanting
white power to millions of your
supporters
you've said that black person he's
getting it asked again exercising their
first amendment rights should be fired
what do you say to americans who say
that kind of language from a president
is contributing to a climate of hate and
racial strife well you have to
understand the first time i ever heard
of black lives matter
they were chanting pigs in a blanket
talking about police pigs
pigs talking about our police pigs in a
blanket fry them
like bacon i said that's a horrible
thing and they were marching down
the street and that was my first glimpse
of black lives matter i thought it was a
terrible thing
as far as my relationships with
all people i think i have great
relationships with all people
i am the least racist person in this
room
what do you say to americans who are
buying that rhetoric i don't know
i mean i don't know what to say i got
criminal justice reform done in prison
that's right opportunity zones i took
care of black colleges and universities
i don't know what to say they can say
anything i mean
they can say anything it's a very it
makes me sad
because i am i am the least racist
person i can't even see the audience
because it's so dark
but i don't care who's in the audience
i'm the least racist person in this room
okay vice president let me ask you
questions
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he started
off his campaign coming down the
escalator saying he's getting rid of
those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse
he says to them about the poor boys
stand down and stand ready
president trump i'm gonna give you ten
seconds to respond and then i have a
phone he
made a reference to abraham lincoln
where did that come in i mean you said
abraham linda where did that no no i
said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done what i've done for the black
community and i'm saying it is a shame
i said not since abraham lincoln has
anybody done what i've done for the
black community
now you have done nothing other than the
crime bill
which put oh god that tens of thousands
of black men mostly in jail
all right you know what yeah you look at
what's happening with the voting right
now
let me ask you they remember them very
very badly
take a look at what's happening out
there vice president let me give you a
chance to respond within this context
crime bills that you supported in the
80s and 90s
contributed to the incarceration of tens
of thousands of young black men
who had small amounts of drugs in their
possession yes their sons they are
brothers their fathers their
uncles whose families are still to this
day some of them
suffering the consequences so speak to
those families
all 100 senators voted for it a bill on
a good job on how to deal with drugs it
was a mistake yeah
across the board that's not what you
said
i've touched my computer i've been
trying to do that's what i'm going to
get done
because i think the american people have
now seen
that in fact it was a mistake to pass
those laws related to the drug but they
were not in the crime bill
but why didn't he get it done see it's
all talk no actually yeah reduce policy
yes exactly why
that's what i'm gonna do when i become
president you were vice president
along with obama as your president your
leader for eight years
why didn't you get it done you had eight
years to get it done now you're saying
you're gonna get it done
because you're all talk and no action we
got a lot of it done
we released 38 they got 38 000 prisoners
left
nothing done 38 000 prisoners were
released from federal prison
we have there were over a thousand
people who were giving credit
you don't go through the project where
they weren't put into
legislation violations of practice the
police
departments of what they were doing how
they were conducting themselves
that's why i'm running to win back that
election and change his terrible
policies
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short
time ago why didn't you do it you just
said i'm going to do that i'm going to
do this
thousands of mostly black young men
in prison now you're saying you're going
to get you're going to undo that
why didn't you get it done you had eight
years with obama you know why joe
because you're old talk
and no action all right vice president
and then we're going to move on to the
next section
we had a republican congress
he's going to eat those words when he
does not talk mcconnell into doing
anything
sorry he was talking about
the other party into things president
you have said you see addressing climate
change as an opportunity to create
new jobs for each of you
elections it's a very tight race okay
why he's motivated to do what he's doing
so we have the trillion trees program
we have so many different programs i do
love the environment but what i want is
the cleanest
crystal clear water the cleanest air we
have the best
lowest number in carbon emissions which
is a big standard that i notice
obama goes with all the time not joe i
haven't heard joe use the term because
i'm not sure he knows what it represents
or means but i have heard obama
we have the best carbon emission
numbers that we've had in 35 years
under this administration we are working
so well with industry but here's what we
can't do
look at china how filthy it is look at
russia
look at india it's filthy the
the air is filthy the paris accord i
took us out because we were going to
have to spend
trillions of dollars and we were treated
very unfairly
when they put us in there they did us a
great disservice they were going to take
away our businesses
i will not sacrifice tens of millions of
jobs
thousands and thousands of companies
because of
the paris accord it was so unfair china
doesn't kick
in until 2030. russia goes back to a low
standard and we
kicked in right away it would have been
it would have been it would have
destroyed our businesses so
you ready we have done an incredible job
environmentally
we have the cleanest air the cleanest
water and the best carbon emission
standards that we've seen in many many
years
vice president we haven't destroyed our
industries
vice president two minutes to you
uninterrupted
climate change climate warming global
warming is an existential threat to
humanity
we have a moral obligation to deal with
it
and we're told by all the leading
scientists in the world we don't have
much time we're going to pass the point
of no return
within the next eight to ten years four
years of this man
eliminating all the regulations that
were put in by us
to clean up the climate to clean up to
limit
the the limit of emissions will put us
in a position where we're going to be in
real trouble here's where we have a
great opportunity
i was able to get both all the
environmental organizations as well as
labor the people worried about jobs to
support
my climate plan because what it does it
will create
millions of new good paying jobs wow
we're going to invest
in for example 500 000
50 000 50 000 charging stations
on our highways so that we can own the
electric car market of the future
in the meantime china is doing that
we're going to be in a position
environmental destruction involved
that we're going to producing an
electric car 15 billion
buildings and 2 million existing homes
and retrofit them so they don't
leak
and by the way the whole idea you put an
electric
whatever that's a one deal thing that's
millions it's not exactly a long job
security situation
and our jobs are at stake that's what's
happening
and what right now by the way wall
street firms indicated that
my plan my my plan will in fact create
18.6 million jobs seven million more
than his this is from wall street
and i'll create one trillion dollars
more in economic growth
than his proposal does not on climate
just on the economy
president trump they came out and said
very strongly
six thousand five hundred dollars will
be taken away from families under his
plan
that his plan is an economic disaster if
you look at what he wants to do you know
the
if you look at his plan his
environmental
i mean she's got a good line of stuff
but she knows nothing he just conflated
tax policy with climate change true
hoops for aoc plus three
look their real plan cost a hundred
trillion dollars
if we had the best year in the history
of our country for a hundred years
we would not even come close to a number
like that
when he says buildings they want to take
buildings down because i want to make
bigger windows into smaller windows
as far as they're concerned if you had
no window it would be a lovely thing
this is the craziest plan that anybody
has ever seen
and this wasn't done by smart people
this wasn't done by anybody frankly i
don't even know how it can be good
politically
they want to spend a hundred trillion
dollars that's their real number he's
trying to say it was six
it's a hundred trillion dollars they
want to knock down buildings and build
new buildings with little
tiny small windows i mean and many other
things
and many other things let me have the
vice president respond and we're running
out of time and we have a lot more
questions
your questions
no
this is planned endorsed by every major
every major environmental group
and every labor group labor because they
know the future lies
the future lies and thus being able to
breathe and they know they're good jobs
and getting us there
just heating up the best growing
industry in america are
is is the electric the uh
no it's forgetting solar energy and wind
he thinks wind causes cancer
the fastest growing job and they pay
good
prevailing wages 45 50 bucks an hour
we can grow and we can be cleaner
if we go the route i'm proposing
president trump
please respond we are energy independent
for the first time
we don't need all of these countries
that we have fighting
we are energy independent i know more
about wind than you do
it's extremely expensive that i agree
with it kills all the birds
it's very intermittent got a lot of
problems
independent
but we still have to import because of
the type of oil that our refineries can
can make into gasoline so it's about the
type of oil it's about the type of oil
that we produce is
but you know what we'll do we're going
to have the greatest economy in the
world
but if you want to kill the economy get
rid of your
oil industry you want and and what about
fracking
all right let me let me let me allow
vice president to respond
is make sure that we can capture the
emissions
from the floor on healthcare capture the
emissions from gas
we can do that by investing money
and doing it it's a transition four
specifications
i am against fracking until he got the
nomination went to pennsylvania then he
said
but you know what pennsylvania he'll be
against it very soon because his party
is totally against fracking on federal
land i said no
fracking using no oil on federal let me
ask this final question
in this section and then i want to move
on to our final
section president trump people of color
are much more likely to live near oil
refineries and chemical plants
in texas there are families who worry
the plants near them are making them
sick
your administration has rolled back
regulations on these kinds of facilities
why should these families give you
another four years in office
the families that we're talking about
are employed heavily and they're making
a lot of money more money than they've
ever made
if you look at the kind of numbers that
we produce for hispanic
or black or asian it's nine times
greater the percentage gain
than it was under in three years that it
was under
eight years of the two of them
to put it nicely
somebody had not
but they're making a tremendous amount
of money economically we saved it and i
saved it again a number of months ago
when oil was crashing because of the
pandemic
we saved it we got say what you want
about relationship we got saudi arabia
mexico and russia to cut back way back
we saved our oil industry
and now it's very vibrant together and
everybody has very inexpensive gasoline
vice president your
my response is that those people live on
what they call fence lines he doesn't
understand this
they live near chemical plants that in
fact first time i've ever heard
any place including in houston at the
time why they're not doing tax plans and
talking about this i
just drive me to school turn to the
windshield but there'd be oil slick in
the window
what do you do
yes oh transition it is a big statement
because i would stop because
significantly i said here's the deal but
that's a big step
well if you let me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
the gas i'm
sure me to the and wind
yeah why are we giving it to the oil
industry we actually do that right the
solar wind
that's maybe the biggest statement in
terms of business that's the biggest
thing
because basically what he's saying is he
is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas we don't remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma vice president
let me give you 10 seconds and i have to
get to the final question
vice president takes everything out of
context but the point is
look we have to move towards the biggest
the biggest solar etf is trading down
right now
the first place to do that by the year
2035 is an energy production
by 2050 totally all right is he going to
get china to do it
we're finished with is he going to get
chinese
and this first question does go to you
president trump
imagine this is
we have to make a country totally
successful as it was prior to the plague
coming in from china
now we're rebuilding it and we're doing
record numbers 11.4 million jobs in a
short period of time etc but i will tell
you go back
before the play came in just before i
was getting calls from people that were
not normally people that would call me
they wanted to get together we had the
best
black unemployment numbers in the
history of our country
hispanic women asian
people with diplomas with no diplomas
mit graduates number one in the class
everybody had the best numbers and you
know what the other side
wanted to get together they wanted to
unify success
is going to bring us together we are on
the road to success
but i'm cutting taxes and he wants to
raise everybody's taxes and he wants to
put new regulations on everything
he will kill it if he gets in you will
have a depression the likes of which
you've never seen
your 401ks will go to hell and it'll be
a very very sad day for this country
all right vice president biden same
question to you what will you say
during your inaugural address to
americans who did not vote for you
i will say i'm an american president
i represent all of you whether you voted
for me or against me and i'm going to
make sure that you're represented
i'm going to give you hope we're going
to move we're going to choose science
over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because there's
enormous opportunities enormous
opportunities to make things better
we can grow this economy we can deal
with the systemic racism
at the same time we can make sure the
same questions
run and moved and motivated by clean
energy
creating millions of new jobs and that's
the fact that's what we're going to do
and i'm going to say as i said in the
beginning what is on the ballot here
is the character of this country decency
honor respect treating people with
dignity
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been in the last four years
all right
i want to thank you both for very robust
first of all phenomenal job to the
moderator honestly
great job if you're on twitter man i'm
sending her a shout out i thought she's
an important job
because this lady tonight
election day is november 3rd don't
forget
folks if you're watching let me just ask
the people if you watch if you're
watching if you're watching if you're
watching
uh first of all just for algorithm
purposes press the thumbs up hit the
subscribe button and the notification
button but comment below
who do you think won the debate between
the two and which parts were the ones
that stuck out to you
i'm asking them the question i'm asking
us the question
daniel why don't you go first i i do
think that
he that but the one area where biden
shine the brightest and i'm looking at
the front page of the wall street
journal for tomorrow morning right now
i'm looking at the wall street journal's
website
is healthcare no question about it and
and that was where he was
i mean okay he's been gone for five days
right so he had plenty of time to
rehearse the answers
but that was where he actually came up
with a cohesive plan
and again in the 60 minutes interview
and again tonight on stage
trump does not have a plan and in the
middle of a pandemic
you should be able to say to people if
they're insecure about health care
that you have a solid plan that's been
well thought out that's not going to
bankrupt the com
the country and that is i mean that is
typically what republicans do right they
come up with more efficient ways to run
business that's that's their mo so i
think
in that sense he did a very good job
biden
other than that i don't think we learned
much about his platform i don't think we
learned much about
the substance of where he thinks
policies are going i mean
we'll make them pay i'm sorry that china
hasn't paid for generations
and and how how you can say that
that you're going to create millions and
millions of jobs without being a little
bit more specific
and and slowly put the oil industry out
of business no no no no
at least not from where i'm sitting in
texas football score
your football person football score
i i i would say that that was a low
scoring high defense game
it's probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of 21 to 14.
trump i have to say trump okay stood his
ground
okay adam um i agree
number one i i kept kind of kept a tail
of tape a little scorecard here
vine definitely won on health care trump
definitely won on the crime bill
uh i will say trump acted
for a change somewhat presidential
somewhat presidential he wasn't as
childish as usual
i think the fact that he wasn't allowed
to speak over his
uh two minutes helped him because you
know that he was
itching to to get out there um he only
went into overtime for like two seconds
once and
a couple of times he got caught up it
helped him
because the first time he kept over
going over going it was not a good look
yeah
uh he did try to come throw in some
jokes in there he had a funny line about
um
he had a couple funny lines sort of the
end where you know the crowd got got a
little uh
a little wild we're the crowd we're the
crow obviously the crowd virtually here
um but there was a couple good lines
that he got i'm giving this 1714
trump okay tom let me just
start by saying i'm really scared for
america i don't think we
truly understand how important this
election is and what what is going on
here
if there's a fundamental difference in
just values or or
philosophies joe biden preys on fear
and he wants to show you every single
way the government can take care of you
led by him
everything is twisted that way and then
he looks at the camera every now and
then
and does his little rehearsed monologue
where he thinks he's speaking to middle
america
intelligent people can see through that
there is such a hatred for
trump that there's a vacuum when you
watch this
people are more concerned about his
rudeness to a moderator than what's
going on in this country the word antifa
wasn't mentioned tonight they spent more
time on the
on the environment than antifa which is
going on is a big deal in major cities
and if joe biden wins the election it's
going to continue to be a big deal
so i'll give it a score of 38 to 3. if
you could get past your irrational
hatred for donald trump
if you can get past that if you just
looked at this objectively
and listen to the points of where this
country's going and who's going to take
it there
he dominated this debate it's
interesting to use objectively
you know interesting three to come back
at me with something substantive
substantive
saying that trump won the debate i'm
saying i see the difference between you
and i my friend
is that i have the ability to call
[ __ ] on both sides you can only call
[ __ ]
i'm biden said because
and with him mentioning the word
integrity i mean i thought that was bad
choice on him tonight because the fbi is
going to own that computer tomorrow when
you can call [ __ ] on both sides
you'll have a lot of credibility i
promise but you know what
these are also the same people that are
saying trump is racist is he i mean are
there real is there real true evidence
that he is i don't think there is i
haven't seen it you haven't seen it
well tell me what it is tell me the
races we don't have enough time to go
down
trump's racist rhetoric and dog whistles
we don't have time for that
but ricky go ahead sir um 38 to 3 you
agree or no
uh i look
one thing i will give him uh he was a
lot more clear this time
um as far as binding was concerned he
was more clear on things
and if you were voting for him if you're
his supporter
today may have a little bit more
solidified it because he didn't sound
incoherent he was
engaged um he was quick on his toes
right so from that point i can see why
you would want to support him if you're
already his supporter obviously i'm not
right uh for many reasons uh stepping
back to 1993
in 1994 but um uh as far as that's
concerned i i
is you know like like danielle said as
far as his plan
uh his healthcare plan uh you know he
was very accurate as far as that's
concerned
but one thing i didn't like is that
everything he started was always
accusing the president of something
and and if you have to start from a
defensive standpoint instead of just
trying to point
to try to prove your point um and you're
taking 30 seconds always
but he but he but he but he but he but
he and then and then sitting there
saying you know i'm gonna do this the
hispanic community obviously is a big
part for me
they said we're gonna do this and we're
gonna do that and and trump made a very
good
he made a very very very very good point
when he asked the question
why did you do it in eight years he kept
saying that you had eight years to do it
so you cannot forget that no matter how
good biden sounded today and how
coherent he finally was
the fact that he was the last vice
president and that was only three in the
court like three and a quarter years ago
it wasn't something that would happen
ten years ago actually biden answered
him
because they didn't have congress and
that's exactly why the republicans today
have a supreme court justice and they
will have a supreme court justice
because they do have the senate so you i
mean obamacare
was a one one-and-done in eight years
obama came in and passed
one major piece of legislation and then
it may as well have been a lame duck
presidency for the next seven years okay
fair enough fair enough but every
american blames trump for everything as
if he had the power to do everything
and we're not doing the same thing to
buy them so well i didn't have the time
to schools are very close in
a lot of places i don't i don't know why
there's this perception that that that
trump has hated if you look
no no no no if you look at these swing
states
uh critical uh swing states critical
states yeah then the polls are still
running neck and neck
you know i agree with you but what i'm
getting at is as far as
as far as accountability is concerned
right if
if the tv would have turned off oh it's
trump's fault but when his body was
because he didn't have this or because
they didn't have that
it's always it's always i don't know am
i wrong when i say that it's
there's always an excuse when it comes
to accountability it's always boom
it's deflected but it's trump everything
oh it's his fault it's his fault it's
his phone as he had completely
if he was some dictator that could
completely control everything that's
going on but
if i had to score between both of them
you know like
i just i just don't like biting i just
he kicks my people
he engaged my people and he deported
four million of them and then
i grew up around crips and bloods and i
went to school with crips and bloods and
non-binding and then he says what really
got something when he when he lies is we
released 38 000
federal prisoners look i have family in
federal prison okay here's the reality
behind things
unless you're moving big weight you're
not going to even touch a federal case
so the people that he incarcerated were
not federal cases
there was a guy that had a 20 sack of
weed or heroin or cocaine in this bucket
shouldn't have had it those are the guys
that he locked up for a long time not
federal cases
so try to deflect the fact that you
locked up by the masses
these and then well federally we've
released them you you go to when you're
a federal person you're going with
lawyers
doctors you're going with government
officials there's something corrupt
and very high weight drug dealers you're
not going with the guy that had a 20
second sponsor
that's a pound won't get you to the
federal federal prison so
that has led to the downfall of many
minority
families in america absolutely i mean
so he does you know an lbj what he did
lbj was incentivizing incentivizing
uh father absence and then this guy
coming in and knocking a lot of them up
i'm just you know i'm gonna i'm gonna go
i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna go uh
maybe 25 25 8 on this or whatever
you feel maybe one field goal or
whatever you know with me i i don't know
twenty five eight you're thinking about
the other football yeah
the thing is i don't even care has there
ever been a football game that ended
with a team scoring 25 points
i'm a big footballer
you've been doing your diligence over
there you've been keeping score i know
you've been keeping uh
first of all you know what i love about
the current
group that we have is your center
right your center left you're where you
are
i'm center right say middle to center
right
is where i'm at i think the the this is
great because the audience that's
watching this you want to see this it's
not everybody on one side
or body on the other side you call out
trump uh one minute next minute you're
calling out biden
you know adam will only call out uh uh
uh trump but
for the most part you know and i said
trump the one with the debate but here's
the thing so here's here's where i got
here's why here's what i got let me tell
you what happened here this whole
[ __ ]
this is this is a couple things i got
one um
lines that were very good trump we can't
lock ourselves up in a basement like joe
has
okay sorry we can't lock ourselves up uh
in the basement like joe has okay that
was the moment he said that that's
hilarious he's been using it
it's not my fault that the virus came
here it's also not
biden's sounds phenomenal because we've
now
seen what was a moment of grace no
question about it we've not seen
one moment where it's been kind of like
humility humility
i i i loved seeing him i thought it was
great that he said that
and it it probably brought some set
where people said well maybe he's got
that kind of a side to him that we don't
know about
then there was another one that said
they paid you a lot of money and they
probably still are
trump said that i guarantee you if i
spend a million dollars on you i would
find out a ton on you
if i spend a million on you look how
much they spent 35 million dollars on me
and they found nothing on me with russia
if i spend a million i'll find out i
think that's a very powerful one
the other one is when biden said
he thinks he's running against another
guy this is joe biden i'm here because i
beat all those other guys
i love that line the fact that he said
that i think that's a very powerful
confuse for buying you confused me with
bernie meaning that's what he said
that was his
i agree with you and then the one with
me on trump
that that got me like you know how you
feel statement and feeling when joe said
that i felt it
i'm gonna tell you which one it was
i want to say let me explain to you why
i started a business
because of a guy yup yeah you say two
words to me i said i'm gonna start a
business and i'm gonna whoop
your ass just because of your words when
he said i ran because of you
oh my gosh i ran because of you joe
because of what you did i had a great
life but i ran because of
you are you kidding me that's a way
that's that's a lot of weight behind
that statement
and then he says uh uh then when they
brought i think this one's gonna get him
in trouble when biden says
you know it's also the laptop is another
rush and then
trump says wait a minute the laptops
another russia really this is a new one
the laptop's another russian
he's gonna run with that one and then
the whole thing with why couldn't you
get it done if you had all these years
but but but the conversation
trump got what he wanted to get out of
it trump said here's the one thing that
biden can't hold them
can't control himself with biden doesn't
have to
answer three things he answered it he
should have never answered it
it was over moved on okay like when he
says
tell me what you're gonna do with oil
but tell me what you're gonna do with
oil you're going to do this this is a
big thing
by the way just so everybody knows texas
pennsylvania pay very close into
i hope you got what he said here's what
he's going to do because he needs texas
he needs pennsylvania that was a big
point that he had there and you know
trump's going to know how to
uh run with that i i think to me
trump um trump schooled him if you ask
me i mean obviously the score isn't like
a
shellacking it's a 28-14 score that i
got he beat him by two touchdowns
but i think trump did exactly you know
when you're
you're debating somebody like there
wasn't a moment where biden pulled him
in
and then he he got him to say what he
wanted him to say i don't know if that
makes sense
he pulled bite never did that but he
pulled them in
and penced it as well in this debate if
you remember that pence did the same
thing as well
so are you going to pack the courts also
is it fair to say he still has a are you
going to pack the courts
are you oh let me talk about corps
packing the court how about we talk
about that out of all the judges that
you have not one of them is
african-american which is not true
but pence needed that and he got it i
don't think
uh uh uh biden didn't play any fleet
flickers i think trump did and he got
him
28 to 14 trump wins this one so well
we'll know within like 48 hours because
it's just like the last debate we'll be
able to see who raises money and see who
raises money fast
yeah but there's there's more to the
story of what's going to happen tomorrow
i mean people might not be talking about
the debate
as much yeah you know i know
taking the week off didn't help him i
really don't i think you can try to
rehearse or get yourself prepared for a
debate
you got to be able to think on your feet
and i think with trump doing talking to
the media every single day
doing these rallies he's used to
responding quickly
which is what you have to do and you got
to capture the moment and and trump was
able to do that plus he showed
that he's coachable that he can reel
himself in if he had been off the grid
tonight
he wouldn't help himself at all but at
least he he reigned it in and he came
across
as much more presidential and at one
point i thought he was going to turn
purple but yes
there's no doubt in my mind that trump
won this debate and this is someone who
is not a fan of trump and i'm able to
call both sides
like i see it there's no doubt that he
won this debate
but like we're using sports analogies
we're using football analogies
all biden has to do
was not turn over to the football he's
looking to run out the clock
he's ahead in a lot of the swing stages
which pat
as always says is a bad way to think
about it i'm thinking about it but biden
wasn't taking any crazy shots
he wasn't trying to get into crazy
arguments
listen again i think trump's one but
biden wasn't trying to get too crazy
tonight
so so take a think about it this way
okay
i'm with bill o'reilly we're on a flight
together okay
so happens we're going to vegas because
i'm going to watch him when he was doing
the whole thing with him and dennis
remember when him and stewart were doing
things they did that really cool
i love him it's freaking phenomenal man
what those guys were doing jon stewart
jon stewart thing but he was doing this
one in vegas with miller so i went to
watch him and miller
and i wanted to watch him in stuart
phenomenal whenever you get these types
of things happen you got to go to it
and i said so what happened with romney
and obama
he says i got to tell you he says i
called both of them
and i said president obama you know i
was telling
he's got to get on he's got to do one
last interview because romney's got this
one
romney's got this one romney's got this
one he says president obama's campaign
manager told me one thing
when we were on the phone he says bill
this is where you're wrong
obama's already won this and bill says
what do you mean
he says romney had a chance to beat
obama
he made one big mistake what's that his
campaign manager told him
that you don't have the single woman
vote don't go too strong against
obama and benghazi don't do it women
don't like it
what does romney do never brings up
benghazi on the last debate what was
romney's best debate
not the last one it was the one prior to
that what ends up happening
romney needs it romney thinks he's got
it but obama didn't need it
and he was right obama wanted right
because he had momentum and don't forget
what sandy hook did to obama
sandy hook chris christie that whole you
know that all that stuff that was taken
from
her
hurricane sandy so don't forget that
timing on what happened there right okay
when christy came out and greeted him
for you to think
like oh we got it oh brother andy grove
said only the paranoid survive
and i'm telling you right now democrats
are not paranoid
trump looks paranoid so he's going next
next
next camp next one next one next one
reagan was running years ago
and he thought he had it's like oh
america loves me there's no way the
other guy's gonna win
finally bush comes up just listen you
got to go out there campaigning so
and he was older you got to go out there
campaigning you don't have this one
locked in the other one's getting
momentum
then he went in trump is the most
paranoid candidate we've ever had
i don't think there's been a president
more paranoid than him
is to come up short by just a little bit
then his campaign can look back on these
five missed days
but you know what i don't think it's
going to be someone's going to win big
because someone's going to dominate
these swing states and it's going to
it's going to tip it and i i i don't see
it being close
i don't even mean by dominate the swing
statement i i think some if someone wins
one of these swing states they're going
to win them all
i think i think maybe we don't know who
it is we don't know what the polling is
but
whoever wins i don't think the election
will be close this feels like it's a lot
this feels like gore bush this feels
like florida's really important right
now
it really does i'm not saying florida
isn't important but i'm saying i'm
lumping a lot of these swing states
together
if whatever tipped florida is going to
tip michigan wisconsin
minnesota and i i just i think that some
there's going to be a bigger margin of
victory for whoever ends up winning this
biden's camp is too cocky to me you
can't win like that you can't go in the
fight being too cocky how many times
have you seen a champion going to a
boxing match
and you know or somebody goes and being
too cocky what happens to them oh
there's no way in the world you know
this part of the dust buster douglas
beating me up mike tyson boom
what the hell just happened and then
from there this is what they're going in
democrats
see obama wasn't like this if you think
about obama obama wasn't like this obama
if you ever watch obama's debates it's
unbelievable
because obama knew how to do like that
one thing trump did today i've never
seen him do before i've never seen him
do that before he says
this is not my fault neither is it joe's
fault
this is china's fault so what do you say
you can't respond to it by the way
that's obama's strength
that is obama's strength obama when he
gave his dnc talk he gave the talk he
says
this is not about red this is not about
blue this is not about purple
military matters this matters lgbtq
christians matter church coming all
so the way he was able to bring them
together and obama was paranoid when he
was campaigning
hillary was not paranoid hillary was i
am hillary
do you realize who i am i'm guaranteed
locked in to be a president and these
campaign people behind closed doors have
convinced him
that he's locked in and he's not right
he's not locked
i don't think that's necessarily what's
driving his campaign
what do you think's driving his campaign
well i think there's a there i think
there's a different
kind of paranoia driving his campaign i
think they don't want him to mess up
yeah but you can't one like that i'm
just i'm just saying i don't think it's
i don't think it's bravado i think it's
i think i think there's a fear factor
terrible strategy because you can't win
like that yeah but let's see what
happens these next few days i mean
look if if all five of us agree that
trump won this debate
then it's time for the biden campaign to
get hoppin i i
i heard a theory not too long ago i want
to get you guys input on it
because i really don't know what to
think about it sounds interesting that
uh
you know abiding 78 years old right by
the time you leave office he'd be 82
right making him one of the oldest
presidents we've ever had the oldest if
not the oldest dancers because trump was
the oldest when he got elected
right right will be 77 but turn 78.
so here's here's here's the here's the
here's somebody somebody said something
that was very interesting
they said kamala
harris would be vice president what
they'll do is that
the the input the 25th
right make it to where biden is not
no longer fit to be present and kamala
were kicked in as president oh that
that's a done deal
have you heard that before yeah i've
never heard that first time i heard oh i
i believe it
what are you guys because that's why
pelosi brought it up but
i i think that that is that that is the
most powerful message
that the gop can deliver right now is
just what you described
as far as what do you for the people
that don't understand
you know the the fear factor that
that the republican party is using right
now against biden is you're not voting
for him you're voting for her
right and that's why that's why jamie
dimon the head of
jpmorgan chase large benefactors
uh who were fairly centrist uh who are
for biden have said
oh no it's going to be all about his
cabinet it's going to be all about the
people he puts around him
which you know in reagan and reagan's
second term
that was what it was i mean reagan had
to have his people around him because
towards the end of his second term he
was senile
so but that is kind of that is where
that's where the democratic party wants
to lean the narrative
is no no he's going to surround himself
by other centrists like him
it's not going to be aoc it's not going
to be kamala it's it but
but the republicans need to continue to
push this
because the thing that do you believe in
that's my question do you believe it
i don't know i don't know does it does
it
do you know why i don't know because
because when rumors hit twitter this
afternoon that
that bernie sanders might be his labor
secretary that's not exactly what jamie
dimon was talking about
with trying to name people who would be
who would be considered to be
and perceived to be centrist i'm sorry
but bernie does not fit that bill no
you know it's funny because wasn't the
fbi like a huge part of the story
in 2016 right near the very very end
well the fbi is a pretty big piece of it
right now huge story starting tomorrow
i got a question for danielle danielle
these numbers right here
uh uh kai can the audience see this or
are we are we the only ones that can see
this if you can share this or the
audience can see this i want them to see
it
so this is the tax plan comparing
bidens against trumps okay trump 21
biden 28 this is the worst worst case it
can be on top
and it's the one on the bottom that
trump is focusing on and saying that the
stock market's going to crash
so out of the four you're looking at
income tax and payroll
it's going to go to 37. uh biden's 52
small business tax 296 396
capital gains 2 23 8 43 4. pull up the
50 cent thing that he did on new york
post he said
62.6 percent in the state of cali state
of new york
uh i know california and 60 in new york
and then 50 cent comes out saying i
don't want to be known as 20 cent
under biden's tax plan says i don't care
about trump i just don't want to pay the
taxes
so when you look at these taxes go back
to the numbers everybody can take a look
at it
when you go back to these taxes matter
of fact make that bigger make us smaller
make that bigger
make us smaller what's going to hurt the
economy the most out of these four
immediately the capital gains tax why is
that
well if if people if if if if there's a
certain biden victory
in 2000 in 2020 then people who are
sitting on a ton of gains on their
in their stock holdings they're gonna
take those gains off the table they're
gonna they're gonna take a much lower
capital gains hit than they will
if they wait until 2021. that's the
biggest risk right now to the stock
market
unpack that again okay so if this is i'm
going to pay a lower tax rate today
this year which means high we've only
got a few weeks left of this year
effectively versus taking the risk that
they passed that capital gains tax hike
quickly such that i would be i would
lose what
20 percentage points of my gains wow so
a lot
so you're saying a lot of people are
going to sell and get out of the stock
market before the end of the year
is that is that investors are sitting on
such a huge
game also you said if they pass this
before he's even inaugurated
they're going to get hammered because
they're not going to take a chance
no no no no taxes aren't going to go up
if biden wins nothing happens in in lame
duck
nada no no time out you just said people
are going to dump it within weeks that's
going to affect the stock market in 2020
in 2020 right because people aren't
going to wait and see if it passes
they're not that's what i'm saying
in 2021 it's not like it's going to come
back up in 2021 well it's the most
overvalued
it's been in the history of the country
so no it's not yeah so there are other
economic factors like
23 million americans collecting
unemployment benefits that are dragging
the economy down all by itself so that's
number one how does this affect
so for example i i i have the answer for
myself but i want to hear from you
somebody that's in this space you're
right billionaires subscribe to quote if
you've not uh
uh you know we put a link to below to
what she does in the comments section if
people want to know what she really does
on how much here i'll call danielle
we'll talk we'll be talking to pat i'm
writing all day today can we talk
thursday and we'll get on the phone
we'll talk the next i know
the days for us to talk this thursday
because she's working non-stop writing
but for me i want you to kind of explain
this from the standpoint of
i'm the small business owner how does
this affect me i'm an average guy
i don't run a business i make 55 000 a
year how does that affect me
i'm an independent contractor making
three hundred thousand dollars a year
how does this affect me
give us you're going to look if you're
if your take-home profits
go back up to the prior peak rate 39.6
is what it was prior
to the trump tax bill if you're if you
know that then you're going to be more
reticent about
expanding your workforce to the same
extent you're not going to make the same
investment
investment you might other otherwise
because you're going to look at the
profit picture and you're looking you're
going to look at
the math of profits differently given
what you know you can take home from
that
so it's going to make you a potentially
more conservative
small business owner which is the last
thing we need at this juncture
with so many small businesses that have
already been lost so danielle question
for you
because you said you were not sure who
you're voting for i'm still not
is seeing something like this this
doesn't sway you
to want to vote more towards trump and
why not
well then it comes down to an
existential question right then it comes
down to
why you would vote for one person over
the other whether or not you were doing
something that was bigger for your
country
and that is i think where the people who
are undecided
why they're undecided i i was out to
dinner with with some friends a few
nights ago this lovely open air west
village blah blah blah area here in
dallas
and he said i've voted republican my
entire life and i know that
i know that i'm going to be paying
higher taxes
and yet i think it's the right thing to
do to vote against
trump and so i think that that is where
some
people have their thinking because they
they view trump as being a divisive
president rather than being a uniting
president again
is he devised oh okay so here's a
question because
i mean he he was asked about the the the
the governor of michigan and he said
you know they're they're chanting lock
her up and he's like no lock them all up
so i mean you
you have to be more like tonight you
have to be more like
that trump more presidential yes more
tactful would you please repeat that and
unpack that because i was
picking up a spill you said the guy was
lifelong republican
lifelong republican he'd always voted
for the republican party his entire life
he knew that it was going to cost him
money in higher taxes because of the
type of company that he
has so he knew he's in real estate but
he knew that he was going to
be paying higher taxes under biden but
yet he felt that
it was the right thing to do for the
country i could not wrap around
my arms around that thought that is
unbelievable that he would say that
and then you couple coronavirus right so
you're buying the ship
we have riots in our streets and we have
a lot of people who connect very
quick dots to it to the fires in the
streets
the lincoln project you've heard of this
lincoln project is basically all former
nationalists
all republicans all republicans they're
former they're former republican
campaign advisers
securities staunch gop they've come out
there's hundreds of them how many
who have all come out and said i can't
support this person i had a conversation
with a
person on the dnc he's a major
fundraiser and he makes it beaucoup a
lot of money and i was like dude
you make a lot of money tell me how you
justify voting
democrat when you know that it's going
to increase your taxes he said kind of
like danielle said
it's bigger than my bigger than me it's
bigger than me and that is
what do you mean what do you mean this
is what i want to know what's the
okay it's bigger i don't know what
you're talking about explain it to me
what's the bigger what
i assume they want to care about the com
the country benefiting over higher taxes
higher taxes solution with china
obviously selling yourself to china
having your son i think they're talking
about i think it's simpler than that i
think it's what's on the evening news
okay that's what i'm talking about so
it's not bigger
people just assume it's bigger well it
is look it's not
the way where she went wait wait was she
why have gun sales in america tripled
since the corona virus
i know i know our household has more
because we are scared of
the narrative the democrats keep pushing
but i i speak to my friends
on the east coast in new york in new
york city these are
these are die hard liberals and they're
they're they're gunning up and i'm like
god you're going to shoot your foot off
i mean i get it here i get it here in
texas
i don't know audrey the whole country is
getting warmed up
i've been in beverly hills i've seen the
riots i've seen the stuff going on i
mean the reason
people are buying i've never owned a gun
in my life ever
i'm going to get a gun i am going to get
a gun
i live in l.a i i mean and it's not the
it's the stuff i see what's going on for
real the stuff they didn't even talk
about on the debate today but very
very important what she said because we
were having a conversation today and he
says pat
if the taxes adam's asking me when i
landed back from i was at jekyll island
last four days i had a whole meeting
there anyways
so so i'll he said pat how about all
these tax stuff you know if that's the
case
why are all these silicon valley people
voting for the left okay
why are all these billion and then we
address that why is wall street why is
wall street voting for the left and so
and wall street know that they are we
don't know exactly how they vote but
he's asking the question
but you said something you said
something right now and then you said
and he says
well how about this how about collusion
how about raising taxes how about your
son this and he went off right
and you said i don't think it's that
complicated i think it's as simple as
what's being said on the news
what they're no no not what's being said
you can have it on mute with what you're
seeing
on the news with the fires in the
streets i think that that says more than
anything else
it's like it's a picture
adam said he talked to his buddy the dnc
and he says it's bigger
what's bigger the lies so you've got to
go and put somebody that's going to make
everybody happy so that you stop the
riots
that's not bigger that's you saying i'm
i'm scared i don't know how to defend my
country
and i'm just going to sit here and cry
about it and i'm just going to put
somebody's going to give us peace
but it's literally going to ruin the
country so it's not bigger
that's if there's a blue sweep if it's
it's
beyond simple okay why are half the
country
for trump and why is half the country
against trump not even it's super simple
it's not naivete
i i i'm letting you know if you want if
you're willing to listen
half the country loves trump because
he's an [ __ ]
because he shakes things up no no
because he'll call [ __ ] because
he'll call out china
and the other half of the country hates
him because he's an [ __ ]
it's just that simple no it is no it
isn't
so why is the country 50 50 tom because
in your world everyone here
we should all love trump he won 38-3 oh
my god he's the best thing ever
but tell me why because i think there's
some people that look at stuff like this
that look at stuff is happening in the
country you guys like
you want to vote for trump you just
won't let yourself no i don't all the
data all the criteria lines up for you
to vote
you like money you like making money you
like keeping your money you like safety
you like going out
if biden is the president say goodbye to
your nightclubs say goodbye to your
parties like a [ __ ] rock star under
obama so what so all of a sudden it's
gonna
who's
are you equating biden to obama i mean
it's obama light there's no
no no coronavirus plus biden means
no fun this country's done shut down
it's over so what happens to our country
it's going to be a slow
slow fall off a cliff so where are you
moving
i haven't decided yet but you're moving
somewhere oh and that
coupled with new signs so you're out of
america i encourage you today in america
the only reason california is not
falling into the pacific ocean is
because so many people are leaving so
it's releasing the weight
right off of the actual landmass i was
talking to somebody today
and i said and i said and which is true
okay
which this is this is a fact i said
listen
trump lowered his uh unemployment for
hispanics and blacks
lowest in history but it's only by a
certain percentage
also now you're going to marginalize
wins so 44 other presidents have never
done it but this man did oh but it's
only by a little bit
so people's reasoning for voting for
biden
when you literally sit there and look at
the policies look at his history
look at what he's done when you look at
and you realize that trump is
beating his ass and every pretty much
every other president of ronald reagan
ronald reagan in the past 44 presidents
you have to start to rationalize why
you're voting for a certain person
because if you look at the policies and
then you look at the reality and you
look at
everything overall trump is the best
choice over biden
and here's your depends on the policy
though depends on what the
the majority of the like if you if
you're a gen xer and your number one
priority is climate change
right and you have a candidate who
basically thinks it's so which policy
would trump do you like the least
which policy do i like with trump let me
get off which one do you like the least
look uh uh here's here's one here's one
that i uh with with biden
i would have thought about it right off
the bat i can tell you what i can tell
you right now i don't like for
the president to make the military in
this country feel compromised
and that is why mattis came out publicly
and said what
see i i disagree i don't you think he's
making the military you don't think he
has full support of the military
i do i i think the negativity there's so
many generals that are coming out there
saying
general stanley mcchrystal a major army
uh veteran just came out and said
there's no way i can vote for this
person oh
just came out two weeks ago and said
this is the worst person i've ever
turned around there were some more
personal things between those two it
wasn't a black and white situation
mattis was interviewed right before the
corona virus and said as
long as he's a sitting president i will
not say one
negative word about trump you cannot ask
me again
when we interviewed him as well because
maybe maybe trump disrespected him
behind closed doors that's never
happened
it wasn't that he said in his op-ed
exactly why he'd come out against
first of all danielle here's that's a
complete different conversation
to me completely different conversation
mattis
married the military true mattis was in
love with a girl
and he decided to say i'm never going to
get married because my wife is the
military
mattis has got a show on hbo's three
episodes four episodes where you watch
this episode by the time you're done
with you're thinking this is like
general patton napoleon and all these
guys combined in one human being
and you just enjoy watching this and god
bless america i'm all for madison i'm
team mattis i'm a hundred percent
100 but but sometimes when you got these
two bad mo fo alpha guys
there is no way mattis can report to
anybody
did did either i mean would add it up is
it seven or eight
deferments between the two candidates
yeah but you know what
military departments did not serve the
country you added up between those two
guys
who was willing to die for america
neither of them
you're more confident that biden's going
to do more for military than trump no i
didn't i did not
say that you said what bothers you the
most that's fair that has nothing to do
with how i feel about you
in our military about a policy what
policy of biden
do you love the most and what policy of
trump does that's an easy answer it's a
headline on the newspaper right now
healthcare
true health healthcare's your number one
trump has been saying
you for the last three months i've
talked to you you've never brought up
healthcare now we talked about it
tonight it was the number one issue
you're for you your number one reason
why you're not going to do trump is
healthcare
never brought it up before it just
happened now was it not a big factor
wait it just happened now
it just happened now so the point he's
making he's right with you
i fully understand what you're saying
danielle i agree with you
because where you're coming from i'm a
maddest guy i'm the guy that says
you gotta listen to him mattis here's a
guy what are you doing not listening to
a guy like madison are you kidding me
everybody in the military respect
i'm an army guy he's a marine guy he
saluted him we spoke the first time i
said
we look up we brought him to the company
to speak and we had a marine interview
him
and he's not a trump guy so we're very
comfortable doing something like that
but
the question he asked is if somebody
who's in the middle
you said what it looks like on tv i do
agree
which a big part of voting is what
people are seeing on tv
and i sometimes wonder and i said or
social media whatever
if we took out right now social media
okay it isn't it is 1964
first debate that was nixon kennedy okay
on tv
you know you know which one i'm talking
about i don't know what the year is the
sweat the sweat right right i sweat
if we have no tv if the only if we have
the first tv we have but not as crazy
like you know the way the media is
manipulating today was overall to
cronkite saw more people were
if we don't have that these two faced
off with each other
and the principles they're both selling
based on what america was founded on
there is no all the other stuff that we
have going on
who would be crushing the other one
based on the uh
policies that they have it wouldn't even
be close based on the first debate it
would definitely be close based on
tonight's debate
it would have been trump yeah it's not
even close and i'm not even talking
about
personalities i'm purely talking
policies
trump's personality there's a book i
read called barbarians to bureaucrats
he says in in every great company
and society and organization there's
what there's a dreamer
yeah there's a prophet uh no no there's
there's a
oh that's right that's right what's the
there's a no he says
there's a dreamer there's a uh engineer
and there's a son of a [ __ ]
right yes you have to have a son but
you've
got to have it and that guy is an
absolute qualified
son of a [ __ ] and people like that
sometimes but the president doesn't have
to be the scientist i actually don't
mind it i don't mind it listen
i do not mind it especially don't mind
the tough issues man
you know a guy a guy who was a democrat
i was watching his video today he
gave a message 1.2 million views
in like two days and he says i'm not a
trump guy
he says you guys got to realize i didn't
vote for trump when the first time
around
he says but i got to tell you he says in
any other
season trump would be a terrible
president
a terrible candidate a terrible person
to run america
he says well for today he is the perfect
person
for america today a sitting democrat
yeah you should
i was experiencing today he said because
today there are so many people that are
trying to
leech and take stuff from america
because america has been able to
give up side deals to china for decades
and decades and decades
and america is the one that's allowed
china to go from a top
20 to top 10 to top five to not
competing number two
fighting for first place he says the
only person that can go against somebody
like that
is only a guy like that nobody else can
pull it off right and he's the only guy
chinese
so i don't know if he's right or not but
that part of it for me and what makes us
weaker
than than not standing up to china that
trump has done
signing in socialism light being an
agreement
going on national television yesterday
morning and saying that nancy's
bill wasn't big enough i'm sorry but i
don't disagree with you there we're on
the same but again if if he continues to
run up our national debt to the extent
that he is that makes us extreme that
makes him more vulnerable
than any rhetorical war with china he
needs to focus on our national debt and
on semiconductors
not soybeans he needs to understand that
the chinese have already moved on to the
next stage
he can't do that the leader of our the
leader of our country has to do that
you and i are not going to agree with
them you and i are not going to agree
with them here's how the situation works
here's how this thing works okay first
let's create a massive crisis what's a
massive crisis
let's shut down every state let's shut
them down
okay let's let's force trump to do a lot
of cases
[ __ ] okay we'll do a lot of cases let's
get everybody tested
then trump does testing we have a
million cases
you just told me do cases i listen to
you million cases yeah
cases but it's not three five percent
people dying it's one percent
and even if you go deeper it's point one
percent because the people that are not
getting it
it's not the three to five percent you
were saying yeah
so he doesn't have control to get all
these governors that are shutting down
their states
he can't go so you can't do that they're
shutting down their states
they're they're begging for something to
happen then their purpose is
strategy think about it let me go to the
strategy and tell me i'm wrong
here's what he's not going to do what's
he not going to do we're going to say
these people are struggling how dare you
not pass a stimulus
he's not going to say yes to it because
remember what he said under obama
then they come up with a stimulus he
said yes then they're like oh
[ __ ] everybody starts making money
everybody's happy again economy is okay
it's doing a little bit better
10.4 million jobs back 11 million jobs
back say it again he won't do the second
time
he did it again so he played their game
against them he played their game
against them
and has he put has he created any jobs
with all the money that our country is
found
are we are we repairing our bridges are
we repairing our tunnels unfortunately
unfortunately unfortunately he did not
have an alternative
my opinion unfortunately danielle in a
situation like that
i i am i am so with you on the stimulus
i'm the guy that was way i'm
i sat in the meeting with david herzog
the cfo of aig with bob ben moshe one of
the greatest presidents in the history
of business that saved aig
he took 183 billion from the government
gave it back with 21 billion dollars
and then he died three years later from
cancer was on steroids the entire time
till today gm never paid it back i'm all
about some of these big guys going out
of business
i fully get if you're not responsible
with the money that's capitalism i fully
am with it
i'm on the same page with you and yet
he's barking like a seal at what the
federal reserve is doing and printing
money and keeping all the biggest
companies in business
you can if i if he doesn't do it say he
doesn't do it okay let's just say he
doesn't do it
let's go there actually go there for a
second let's say
he can't control the shutdown media and
the governors are saying we're going to
shut down
let's say he doesn't do stimulus you
take me there he doesn't do stimulation
what did he just say uh up on the stage
he just said to biden
sometimes you got to talk him into it
right
mcconnell's people can push through the
the extension of the ppp
why can't he talk his his his gop
sometimes you got to talk him into it
into extending what small bit
the small business relief program that
the money's sitting there
that's not congress he doesn't have
congress daniel but he just said he did
he said sometimes you have to talk about
it
i'm saying what i'm saying to you is
actually let's go there
please go with me okay it is me
do you remember me he's not going to do
stimulus it's not going to stimulus
and i'm sitting around right here okay
and when i walk my dogs danielle when i
walk my dogs i never carry a gun
right before the stimulus happened and
the economy was in shambles and people
were firing people left and right and it
was very ugly remember there was a
moment in may was very scary
i walked my dogs with a gun in my hand
when i'm walking around i walked in with
my hand i hear it i had my gun right
then i was
when i was sleeping i was ready if
somebody comes to my house i'm ready the
reason why
the country's more ready now if if we
didn't do the stimulus
forget about the rights and protesting
america would have been in
shambles we would have had civil war
taking place and what's our national
debt
going to be if we continue every six
months to put a three trillion dollar
band-aid on this
and don't create jobs you corner me as a
leader
if you corner me as a leader if you
corner me as a leader
and you you have control over the media
i don't if you tell everybody everyone's
dying i can't control that
he has more control over the media
through his twitter channel
he has control over his social media
account there's newsmax there's
fox there's the other one that
o'reilly's on here's a guy that's from
california
he averaged about 200 viewers here's a
guy from california here's a guy that's
living in california my plan was to go
back to california
i told everybody what did i say i'm
going right afterwards i said i'm going
to california
we're going to build a headquarters of
vitamin california or greenwich these
are two places we're looking at
we're going to go to new york the moment
i saw how newsome handled california
i said there's no way i'm going to
california trump cannot do nothing to
newsom
even trump cannot say open disney
land with some real you know
comprehensive way to make it safe for
everybody
test them do anything i make no excuses
for nuisance because he already has the
the florida blueprint that shows how
they can reopen
why he had that proof in hand and still
keeps people out of jobs
i i think i think they fully play the
card and one thing that i
one thing that i said i sit down i'm
like simpson why is this guy doing the
stimulus
every time i went back there and doing
the stimulus if he doesn't do the
stimulus
you know we're sitting right here
windows all this stuff
if he didn't do the stimulus you would
have seen
the craziest things happen the next 60
days
you can't tell me as an american human
being you cannot go to work and i'm not
sending you money
it would have been civil war at the
highest level you would have seen the
darkest things
in for a while i have to ask you a
question then
if trump loses during his
lame duck does he extend the cdc
protection for
risk moratoriums for rental moratoriums
rental eviction moratoriums
or does
no no i said if he loses is he going to
extend the rental eviction moratorium
until congress reconvenes and they can
pass stimulus and prevent
millions of american families with
families
these are not individuals these are
these are single moms with kids from
being evicted you know what he's going
to do
you know what he's going to do because
of his personality he's going to let the
whole ship burn what do you think he's
going to do he's going to burn it down
okay i don't disagree i'm not sitting
here saying oh he's not going to do it
he's going to say yeah okay but then
democrats are going to come and they're
going to give it to him the next
you know in fact you can't make you
cannot unwind an eviction
you can't do it no i i guess that's why
people are armed to the teeth
yeah but that's there's a different
reason why he would be doing that it's a
different reason why
if you move if you make this move and
you make this move and i'm getting
cornered
if you corner me i'm sorry i don't know
if you corner any human being in a
situation like this
that doesn't matter who why is he
getting cornered if he loses the
election legitimately that's a different
conversation what i'm talking about she
asked though no
and i agree with yeah okay i just told
her well he would burn the ship down
because he lost no he wouldn't burn the
ship down he just would say that the
renting would not come we're not
covering i i don't think he would burn
the ship down no
i don't think he would burn this [ __ ]
down but yeah i'm saying to you guys
guys we cannot
and none of this is right there's no
morality about this 48
of landlords in america are small
business owners they're getting hosed
they're not covered at all and in
california it's even worse oh it's worse
it's worse but here's looking at him
look i want to ask you a question all
right go go ahead
i want to go back to what you said you
said uh this link in this league
i've heard about one time bro you forget
that
trump was never a republican you're
talking about a guy that just ran with
the republican party
the man is the one that funded jesse
jackson's campaign twice as an
african-american
uh presidential campaign this guy's a
this guy is known to support the
democrats so
if he goes into the republican party and
he and and people don't support him well
no [ __ ]
he was never bitten republican he's
these are his friends
these are not people that he ran with
same thing with uh with uh with the
reason why uh bernie sanders didn't make
it for he's a socialist
a lot of people democrat socialism a lot
of democrats like nah
we're cool bro trump trump in in uh
in in um sanders
fall in the same category sanders is a
socialist
trump is not a republican was not a
republican
so to say what do you agree there well
he didn't have support from the
republicans well no [ __ ]
the guy's only been a republican for
three years and 10 months
of course he's not going to have the
support from the republicans i mean
it's not like he's a lifelong republican
he's an opportunity what are you
responding to
his support amongst republicans is
ridiculously high
ninety percent uh approval right i get
that bro
there's some groups that simply don't
want outsiders
and it's very well could be that this
linkedin group is it some people just
don't want outsiders
period and by the way in the democratic
party happened with sanders
there was a lot of a lot of democrats
and i talked to the conservative
democrats are like bro we're not
supporting sanders period well look what
hillary did in 2016.
with her own democratic national
committee so so so that's on both sides
sanders had a lot of democrats that were
not his supporters because he's an
outsider
the guy's not a democrat he's a
socialist it's that simple so
i don't really put too much weight on
these leaking guys that turn and say
don't vote for trump
well no [ __ ] he's not part of your party
and you just don't want to play ball
he's
he's he's a very difficult guy for
insiders that have been on the inside
for 20 years to let him be the leader
we're like
we've got so control guys like that
don't do well when i when i went into
the insurance business
and all of a sudden i started shaking it
up the insiders never liked me
for a long time until i won them over it
took me a long time to win these guys or
so wait you're not part of the insider
what are you talking about you're not
one of us
most of these guys like my father you
know i'm legacy and all this other stuff
he's not a legacy guys
i'm just coming in right here's what i'm
going to be those are the most hated
types of plus you made them work harder
most difficult hater types because you
got to wake
everybody up you want to get a new guy
i've been able to kick it i've been
golfing i've been
relaxing who the hell are you coming
making us work no i don't like this guy
i don't like this guy so you're saying
those people would rather vote for the
democrat
rather than people someone in the
republican party it's not rather
because at that point it's not about
republican democrat it's about the
community it's about the fraternity of
politicians
it's about who we are we all understand
each other and it's not all these other
we all understand what things we do
behind closed doors winkling type of
stuff
no it's it's not as black and white as
we all think it is
there's some gray area here anyways
listen at the end of the day we don't
get to choose we only got five votes
here
okay and and the five votes and we're in
texas
well he's in california they're in
california and he's in florida
so he's not going to work on the
conclusion
first time first time since 76
you live in california i do you pay the
arguably one of the highest taxes
of anyone in the country i do why are
you still living in california
as far as what my uh why are you still
living in california
you're getting [ __ ] tax wise yes 100
so i got two reasons
yeah i got two reasons reason number one
and by the way that's not i'm not i'm
going to give you my reasons for five
minutes guys yeah this is the last topic
okay the reason number one i'm not going
to give you is not even my strongest
point
but uh all my family is there but that
won't hold me there
right now number two is for business
we're building right now we have
different offices
there's a conversation i had with
patrick we were getting we wanted to
move pat says
reinforce your california your
california area first which
that's what we're gonna do is my
business coach as well hey we're gonna
reinforce uh the
california once you do x y and z just
like he did
he says when i was gonna leave
california i left california i did x y
and z
so he created a game plan for himself he
gave us a blueprint that's what we're
going to do
as soon as that happens we're out of
cali bro so you're thinking about moving
forward
i'm not thinking about it it's going to
happen texas texas
texas is america texas is texas is
america and
if we want it to be we could be our own
country
exporting state in the nation thank you
california
obama ran for president he won there was
twenty five thousand petitions signed so
texas can become his independent state
how is this state up for grabs right now
i don't get it
how about a lot of people here not gonna
get it
some of it is austin's getting very
powerful in austin say austin's not
texas right austin's not at all texas
and there's a big part of houston that's
not texas
and sadly enough because of how the
coronavirus has been handled it has hit
mothers women in the workforce and
minorities the
hardest so in that sense well and then
coupled with the fact that the kids
can't go to school and they have to deal
with those hardships
that's what i'm talking about that's why
mothers have disproportionately had to
drop out of the world by the way a lot
of older people
who were 100 supporting trump in 2016
and up until about six months ago were
all on the trump on the trump train
they're seeing this whole ridiculousness
with the mask
don't wear the mask they're in their 70s
their 80s their 90s believe me
they're reconsidering their vote i don't
trust me on that they're reinforcing it
here we go these are older people who do
not like the way that trump is handling
corruption should have had a shot today
you should have had a shout out to kill
or two
i receive a text message my mom's
godfather which is my uncle which is my
grandma's brother
remember i posted a picture with the
charos when my uncle my cousins are
horse riding
their grandfather which is like my
grandfather just died from coronavirus
as soon as i get back to cali i'm going
straight to modesto oh i'm sorry
thank you but what i'm getting at is
this the oh oh
it's the overall like talking to your
buddy for the seat to see it's no no bro
i'm not going to sacrifice
though my uncle says i was a baby
he died because corona right now still
doesn't swing me because
this country needs a leader not to be
it's okay
no we need leaders and i just lost one
of my closest people to me right now
no patriots need leaders we don't need
to be soft enough to put a pillow on our
ass when we fall
it's that simple it's that simple that's
what it comes down to what a way to
finish the podcast folks i hope you
enjoyed it
uh press the thumbs up subscribe plus
the
click on the notification button and
once the next time we're doing a podcast
daniel are you awesome you're going to
be with us day after election election
day after election daniel's going to
come back are we doing
the night of election election day
election night but we're going to go to
two three o'clock that's gonna be like a
six hour type of deal that we're doing
today
i think we're doing the podcast on
tuesday that's what mario told me so i
think that's the next one
we are doing it this tuesday yes we are
doing it this tuesday
so we will put it up you'll see it but
having said that gang had a really good
time with everybody here
good stuff they can still have fun and
leave have a good night everybody
everybody vote vote we're doing it
tomorrow ourselves
awesome ricky you had to steal the show
at the end
you